foreign
[Music]
thank you
relax
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
in the 2013 Magnus Carlsen became the
world chess champion and at that time at
only 10 years old Olive Russia had only
played the game of chess for one year
and here we are 10 years later it is the
perfect finish to the Julius bear
Generations cup with a match between the
20 year old peruja and 32 year old
Magnus Carlsen a big welcome everyone to
the Grand final of the Julius bear
generation cup
[Music]
he blundered his night
it's full of traps you saw the reactions
like oh crap here we go like what is
this kid got in store it's got to be a
Checkmate right I mean that King
oh my god did he just miss that
Checkmate on the board
oh hello
[Music]
he takes the baits checkmate
foreign
to be here in the studio with your chest
experts Grand Master David Howell
Grandmaster Simon Williams and
international Master Ivanka houska it is
the final day of the Julia's red
generation cup day but what do you
expect from the grand final today first
of all Kyle welcome back thank you
it's the original team back together
again it really is and uh what better
day it's a big final I'm expecting it to
be dramatic no matter what it always is
when these two play each other and
Magnus might start as the favorite but
uh it will be fire on the board yeah and
time
at World Cup win
tournament this
is just not slipping up what would you
say about the version we're seeing of
Magnus Carlson right now pretty good
version yeah it's like the ultimate
version I think in there he's just so
good I mean like you say he's just won
the World Cup and uh I don't know where
he gets his motivation from because he
did that tweet where he said chess
completed yeah and he's basically
completed everything but he continues to
play great chess and to win everything
so yeah incredible incredible play from
him and Ali reservation he needs to be
motivated today to be able to be at
Magnus Garden not only in one match he
will have to win two matches you might
go what do you expect from The Young
Frenchman today well it sounds like this
is a bit of a mission impossible right
he has to beat Magnus twice but we have
seen some minor slips up slip UPS from
Magnus he has blundered on occasion and
I think Ali Reza faruga with his Dynamic
style should just come in with a
fine-tuned opening repertoire he has the
right strategy he has to mix it up he
has to initiate chaos he has to just
have that touch of solidity into the
black pieces yeah and yesterday's day
four was all about finding out who from
the losers bracket would make it to the
Grand Final to face Magnus Carlson today
and then the losers semi-final Abdul
Satora got off to a bad start
this is just beautiful beautiful from
Dennis again I've used that word too
many times beautiful but in this game
but it's just so harmonious look at how
these pieces combine and G5 like you say
is it just Unstoppable here I just don't
see any way oh and it makes them all
wood less than a second on the clock he
does come up with the King David is
there a Finnish blow I do see a check on
his this is incredible technique by uh
Dana slazovic placing the queen taking
care of all the checks and now we're
gonna see a mate on the board and there
it is Checkmate by Dennis luzwick in
game one it's gonna be king versus King
in the end the black rook's gonna give
up give itself up for the pawn and there
it is
takes down not the back of the sattro
is the
chaos button that he's just pressed he
has one Connect Four
50 seconds he plays a move he
immediately reacts and as does the bar
one second is to make a move
Dennis getting very nervous here not
putting this in the back of the net and
yeah this could turn wow evaluation bar
even says that this is level now he's a
caucus oh my gosh look at this it's
turned around
such a man's resilience there how did he
do that yeah I don't know I mean you
turn around for a second so he just
panicked
this is oh I'm really happy to see this
that is it unbelievable
unbelievable chess here unfortunately
for Dennis lazavig after a fantastic run
and a big fight being so close to
Victory a couple of inaccuracies and it
is the end of the road for the 16 year
old
loss of the kids still fighting to
qualify for the tour finals with only
one regular event left before we head to
Toronto eight players will be going
there and most recently Carolina enso
secured their tickets but three spots
are still up for grabs and let's take a
look at the unofficial standings
Magnus crossed on for 75 points Ali
reservous on 150 points the winner of
today's match will gain an additional 50
points but for Ali reservous he has to
win today's match to be secured one of
those spots in Toronto otherwise he will
fight with lasovic in the final event to
gain the points he needs to qualify for
Toronto so David fruja he must be super
motivated just get the job done today
and secure his ticket it's a big big day
for alireza farooja the good news is
even if Magnus Carlson does take it
points wise he's doing pretty well for
Asia and uh he's guaranteed a spot in
division one next time I think he can
play with the pressure off even though
in the back of his mind Toronto it's
such a big price yeah and this is a
golden opportunity for him you know it's
playing final again against Magnus Carl
ton to Toronto that's right it is a big
chance and he's just got to play a
little bit more solid I feel and I never
say that I never like people playing
more solid but he got a bit crushed in
the opening last time so he needs to
change that around a bit in this match
and the final regular event on the tour
it's only three weeks away actually it's
tight these events and that's definitely
going to be an exciting one it should go
down to the wire to figure out either
the last two or three spots yeah I can't
wait there's so much just this time of
year it's pack the chess calendar we
know we'll see Magnus there for Asia
Dennis lazovic and
um yeah this I think this match today is
going to kind of set up it's going to
build that momentum towards the final
now as we built towards the end of the
year yeah yeah definitely that final is
going to be so exciting I mean it was uh
that's where last year was where we got
hands from wasn't it so yeah I wonder
what we're gonna get this year
so that might be interesting yeah
on the board lots of excitement and of
course the prestige of a winning
champions Chester or season yeah but
only today is going to be super exciting
you guys I'm looking forward to lean
back and listen to your commentary of
the Grand Final between Magnus Carlsen
and Ali reservous they actually met only
two days ago in the winners final
Magnus is just Relentless look at him
he's taking everything now Ali Resorts
Magnus Carlson making it look easy today
Chris how much time did he have on the
clock because it's a three seconds
barely any time
oh no but the king might be checking
into a mating net it's gonna get caged
Ali was offer resigns Magnus Carlsen
wrapping it up in three games yeah
without overall say that um
we played three very complicated games
and um
I feel like I handled them really well
it definitely looked brutal on the
scoreboard with three wins for Magnus
Carlsen was it simply domination Eureka
um yes in simple words I mean Magnus one
in three games also the positions were
very chaotic and Magnus himself said it
was a pleasure to play those games so
Ali Reza will need to shake things up do
something that's unexpected if he was to
defeat Magnus definitely what do you
expect from him today Simon he should be
coming in with a different game plan
what do you think I think he needs to
try and change the zero three definitely
that he got in the last one and um he
was playing very interesting chess the
last one but his openings were a bit too
interesting so especially with the black
pieces he was really pushing the
boundaries of what you can get away with
uh in the opening so I think uh he's
just got to tighten up a little bit
there and wait for his opportunities I
mean Magnus is playing great but in a
lot of games there's always an
opportunity against Magnus but it's only
one opportunity that you get normally so
he's just got to wait for that
opportunity and grasp it I feel I think
Magnus described us as actually three
complicated games he said he also did
take some risks in that Winner's final
what do you expect from Magnus today
David yeah I think the reason we love
seeing this match up is because both
players take risks they respect each
other so much but they kind of respect
chess more and they're happy to kind of
go for each other from Magnus I expect
him to do exactly what he's been doing
throughout the tournament he's completed
chess he's done it all he's very relaxed
uh he'll take his chances when they come
but I'm on Simon's side for Asia not
just does he have to win one match
remember he has to win two matches and
the only way to do that is to stay solid
he cannot let Magna strike first Magnus
when he doesn't want to lose he'll shut
things down uh it's all about ferrugia
uh staying solid yeah let's take a look
at the tale of the tape for today's big
and final Magnus Carlsen he is coming
from the winners bracket and if he wins
the match he will be the winner of the
Julius bear generation cup
alireza he has to beat Magnus in two
matches what chances do you give him
Simon
I I I think he's got decent chances I
mean uh you know it's a new day it's a
fresh day he is uh I'm bothered both
unbelievable chess players there's no
doubt about that I couldn't believe it
the other day when uh I only found out
he's been playing for like 12 years or
something I know how the hell did he do
that it's incredible right I mean like
strong David you mentioned it was in a
period of eight years he became world
number two or something is that right
which is just unheard of so he's really
a magical player so he can turn it on
and he needs to today yeah the fact that
he actually started playing chess when
he was only eight nine years old here he
is to face Magnus Carlsen in a match how
uh specialist that really David I mean
it's special for anyone uh for Russia
maybe it's extra special because uh he's
one of the most talented players of this
new generation we talk about generations
and he's meeting the leader of the
current generation the big boss Magnus
Carlson and uh yeah I mean what a world
championship match this could have been
maybe will be someday you never know but
uh either way yeah it's uh it's a big
big day definitely and he is only 20
years old Ivanka if he actually is able
to beat Magnus in those two matches
today to win the tournament where would
we actually rate that in Alvarez's
career
um it would be pretty high up there
because the beat Magnus on demand once
and then twice is going to be phenomenal
phenomenal and then of course didn't
actually do it when everyone doesn't
expect that from him that would also be
Sensational and also bearing in mind
that three nil score line as well from
their previous encounter I would rate
that up pretty highly especially when it
comes to online chess but you know this
is just the start for farouza you know
he's just 20 years old and he's gonna
get better and better yeah but is there
something in there tonight do you think
Simon for alireza a big day in his
career I I think again yeah it's very
possible I mean um he's done it before
against Magnus I mean he's beat him in
many games they've played loads of
contests uh online and it just needs to
be on top form obviously to do it to
have any chance and uh he does need to
do it twice as well which is also a bit
tricky not once twice so good luck yeah
yeah if you were his coach David
what would you tell him what does he
need to do to be able to to do the
incredible and beat Magnus twice I would
say be confident yesterday in the
interview farooja himself mentioned that
the other day was a bit heartbreaking it
was really tough but also do your puzzle
Rush he had a winning position against
Magnus two days ago just one tactic he
let it slip and it all turned around so
if he takes this chance when it comes
who knows it could be his best online
speed chess performance ever yeah well
we're gonna put you guys at home on the
line as well we do have a quiz question
today as well and the question on this
final day of the generation cup is in
2006 Vision on Cross 2800 in rating as
the fourth player in history so who were
the three other players who had achieved
this at that time and let's see what
happened when Simon and David was
introduced to this quiz question
yeah
oh my God okay
so it was
over 2 800 Stakes are high assignment
what are we playing for
[Music]
um
well steaks are surprised for you guys
at home as well because you are playing
or this one the just resigned Ginger GM
t-shirt is it worn Simon yeah I mean
what could be better than um winning a
t-shirt with my face on what a prize
that is is it one um yeah I mean the the
person who wins it will have to find out
that so uh maybe a little bit is that
some whiskey stains we're seeing here
could be from the good night yes right
so uh yes no I think it's a fresh one so
no fitter you're not gonna get any uh
stained t-shirts yeah a surprise that is
a cool t-shirt and if you want to win it
you need to submit your answer on X last
time I was here this was called Twitter
I feel old now
stuff happened in the world remember to
use the hashtag chess Champs uh so
answer that quiz question later today in
the show something very fun is coming up
it's uh Simon and David driving go-karts
thank you
[Music]
okay he's stuck yeah I'm coming I'm
coming for you
[Laughter]
[Music]
what's that Max verstappen I was seeing
there
yeah let's go it was very much a tale of
the hair and the Tortoise but I went to
will who won yeah yeah we're gonna we're
gonna see that in a break uh later on
today right now we are waiting for game
one in the Grand Final with the Magnus
Carlsen taking on 20 year old alireza
fuja they are getting ready the two
players four this brand final it is best
out of four rapid games and if they are
tied
then well actually if they are tied then
Magnus is the winner if the otherwise
everyone wins this much wait no no yes
it's Armageddon I'm kidding
if they are tied then Armageddon to
decide the match another rest of Rouge
that he has to win the match to take it
to eighth second match
here we have the regulations I
apparently need to read those 15 minutes
plus three seconds increment is the time
control and Magnus Carlsen if he wins
the match he will be the winner third
time the season he wins an event in the
Champions chest where Ali reservous has
to win it to take it to a second match
and armaged on tie breaks Magnus hasn't
played those in this tournament do you
think he actually kind of kind of wants
to today well I don't think Magnus would
be averse to playing Armageddon he's got
a great track record historically there
but actually that could work in for
rouge's favor just the fact that Magnus
has had very short matches this uh this
tournament whereas farouza he's had
longer days he's had these long long
battles long grinds and he's had a taste
of Armageddon himself so yeah I think
the longer the match is it could be a
potential eight games today if Borussia
can take it the whole distance uh the
longer he can drag it out postpone the
results I think the greater his chances
become as the younger player do you
agree Simon but the younger player he
wants to drag this out as long as
possible uh yeah I think so I mean he
just needs to start well as well I mean
this is the key thing I think if he
loses the first game to Magnus it's
going to be really really tricky so he
needs to come out and uh yeah have a
good first game so this is going to be
key yeah it's the whole day now magnets
he's been in these situations a bunch of
time being in charge the one who only
needs uh sort of the first match
do you expect him to play some solid I
wouldn't say boring chess but solid
chest Ivanka or could he still take some
chances do you think
Magnus is gonna stick to his style is
generally Universal he's happy to enter
complications if so desired but you know
Magnus has been on a winning formula
this year why not continue that I think
it's up to Ali Reza just to unsettle him
maybe surprise him in the opening keep
that solidity that that David and Simon
have been referring to and then you know
take the adventure when you have the
white pieces
we have been waiting for Magnus Carlsen
to get ready and here he is ready for
game one in the Grand Final and we have
the first move we have the first move it
is a Kingsport opening and foruga has
switched up his opening approach this
nut this time is the Spanish opening the
Roy Lopez two days ago veruga went for
the Sicilian and was quickly punished uh
White got a big attack Magnus wiped him
off the board in that first game so he's
definitely uh spoken to a coach he's
definitely uh kind of Taken on new
advice and this is one of the most solid
setups for black uh at these early
stages what will Magnus go for he's
looking away here he's just picking
which variation to go for this is one of
the main lines this has been played for
hundreds and hundreds of years at the
top levels and uh eventually Magnus
pushes his Pawn to D3 so taking a slower
approach to this game uh copycat here
from frugier and all pieces will stay on
the board here for a long time so it's
going to be tension packed but Rock
Solid for both players uh what do you
think here Simon your production was
correct yeah I think it's a very good
choice um from Abby Razer I wasn't sure
if he might try to Berlin or something
but this is more his kind of style
because uh he's keeping the pieces on he
has great experience as we spoke about
yesterday on the sort of in these kind
of structures he's probably the world's
leading expert in the the Italian which
is very similar to this so he's just uh
he's just keeping it a bit safer but
with potential uh potential to grasp an
opportunity if it does come about and uh
Magnus also obviously knows these
positions pretty well as well doesn't he
so uh you know he's not bad he's played
a couple of games instruction before
just a couple right
um yeah but we have seen Magnus just
take a pause the most natural move is
actually to develop the night there on
the left side of the board move it to
the square in front of the queen and
Magnus has taken the second most popular
move which is just to take a precaution
remove give the cast King some air and
control the g-force yeah is it just me
or is Magnus moving a bit slower than he
usually does considering he's got vast
experience here Magnus basically became
world champion on the back of his uh
kind of play with one E4 and he was
pretty much only using this opening as
white back in the days when he was kind
of rising through the ranks when he was
back in for Russia's age and uh yeah
it's a bit strange it feels like he's
freestyling maybe trying to avoid
ferritious preparation but either way in
past days just this week throughout the
Julius bear generation cup Magnus has
been very fast in the opening uh getting
a quick time advantage against most of
his opponents here he looks surprised so
is that yeah is this a sign he is
surprised is this surprise a sign he has
something very tricky obviously what do
you think possibly yeah it might be just
he's looking for a sophisticated
maneuver um something that ferrugia
won't have expected uh before but the
problem here is that this is so well
explored as we mentioned it's one of the
most popular types of openings in Chess
at least the pawn structure so all the
Maneuvers are well known
it's a bit strange at least to me that
he's thinking uh here for white two
minutes now in the tank yeah maybe he's
just trying to think what what kind of
middle game strategy he wants to go for
here I mean uh there's various ways that
you can play this as whites you can play
it quite slowly
um and and you can just develop your
pieces and he seems to be going for this
strategy here or you can try to strike
in the center uh as well by pushing a
pawn so I guess that's why he's spending
a bit of time it does seem a little bit
odd that he's thinking so much here this
this move is I you know I'm not an
expert in in this this structure at all
but
um I don't know this move personally but
uh also looking at the database it's
only saying that there's been one game
with this bishop move
everyone else has actually just
developed a night is trying to take a
shortcut I'll have a look I mean it does
seem to allow D5 doesn't it that's my
first that's my first thing I'm thinking
because the the bishop is blocking the
Rook white puts the rook in the middle
to attack black center but he's moved
his Bishop in the way of that and that
that allows this typical kind of Martial
idea maybe David I mean that you you're
more of an expert in these positions
Than Me by it certainly and uh the D5
kind of seems natural and he's played it
I think so he's played it and Magnus has
reacted with the typical night maneuver
usually we see the White Knight first
kind of relocate next to the other night
in front of the white king making sure
you're really solid on this side of the
board once the other white knight
reaches here uh with the two pieces uh
you're nearly never in danger you can
hop forward and start attacking the
black king but it definitely feels like
Magnus here it's the white uh pieces
that are cramped black has advanced on
the queen side black has more space over
here black has more space in the center
uh look at all these pawns uh kind of
well Advanced uh in the middle of the
board I think feruja has many reasons to
be happy with the outcome of this
opening uh definitely not worse actually
maybe fighting for the advantage with
black already if Magnus isn't careful
and that being said white is still solid
and I'm expecting Magnus to move his
Queen bring us Rook to the center and
still the central tension as long as it
persists it's a big question who will
hold the advantage later
and for black I guess is whether he
should maintain the tension in the
center should he step the pawn forward
should he just leave the pawns as they
are and try to centralize the works
or is he going to be tempted to actually
Exchange in the middle
it's not for Asia's style to trade off
Pawns in the center uh if we ever do see
black take the white Pawn on e4 then it
becomes very symmetrical and I think
that food was Magnus who's maybe
slightly Superior here in terms of
maneuvering or at least he enjoys
maneuvering more than for Usher
um yeah just feels like a balanced
position but full of richness full of
life here and uh okay farouza now he's
forced Magnus to think but Magnus again
he's dropped
a few minutes here on the clock it's
still early days I'm not used to seeing
this from Magnus normally he's I've
actually played against him in a very
similar type of position and he's not
normally super confident super quick
division uh one it's still early days
this is only game one we did start a few
hours late in division one today but
division two has already been finished
the Grand Final with Jana pomyachi and
Lavon aronian is over with uh Jan
Napoleon winning that match securing him
a spot in the next uh division one event
so we will see Jana pomniacci probably
uh in the next event which is cool
what a field already yeah big players in
napoleonishi if he wins the next event
if he does well there he's got a chance
at getting to Toronto he was in superb
form playing in division two actually it
was like he wasn't a man on a mission
you know just dispatching everyone and
he wants to be in division one and I
suspect as David mentioned he wants to
show everyone what he's capable of and
to actually make it to Toronto as well
incredible match there against uh
lavonaroni and another amazing player
in this one early days Magnus Carlson
down on the clock but now he uh has
alireza fuja thinking a little bit as
well
he does and Magnus he's gone for this
night maneuver so not a typical Spanish
opening plan it's definitely Magnus
freestyling here trying to be a bit
creative uh as Ivanka mentioned not many
games at all in this type of position
but he does have a specific idea in mind
and that's to land the White Knight into
C5 we might see that in a moment first
the queen side is likely going to lock
itself up Magnus is just pushed upon
there and I don't think alireza should
get attempted to take that pawn it would
ruin the black pawn structure so it's
going to get a bit more blocked here
Simon uh who would you pick here and why
yeah I'm I mean black has a space
Advantage so Black's got more pawns
Advanced and it's uh generally a bit
easier to to play a position when you
have more space so uh black can try to
move the queen up with a rook over maybe
but uh White seems to have more squares
available for his pieces though well
there's like one big Square C5
um where the bishop and the Knight are
both pointing and uh maybe at the right
moment white has the opportunity to open
up the C file if he moves The Rook over
two squares because he has the
opportunity to capture a pawn uh there
and and open that file so so there's
there's actually a lot going on here I
mean nothing's been exchanged yet
there's a lot of tension those Pawns in
the middle they're fighting against each
other the pawns on the queen side
fighting against each other and every
single move both players have to
calculate the exchanges and the pushers
and work out who they benefit so it's uh
it's a very very tense position uh from
the opening so far it's super rich right
very rich because I mean for Magnus the
thing that he's going to be running
through his head is you know is Ali Raza
gonna actually lock down the center with
this D4 push and if he does that is
magnus's pieces are they ready for that
closure I am in
and also as you've highlighted there
it's also possible to take the pawn
so many choices so many choices and the
kind of natural continuation of magnus's
plan if he's been consistent would be to
try and land a piece into the square the
square you were talking about early
assignment first time he would kind of
land in the black half of the board and
Knight to C5 here looks nice it looks
pretty attacking this bishop but I guess
the bishop just moves and now uh the
other idea Ivanka mention D4 is actually
a killer threat because it would break
the coordination between White's Knight
and White's bishop and uh this Knight is
actually more vulnerable than it is
strong potentially so magnus's whole
idea it's been building up to this but I
think maybe now he's realizing that it's
not that effective and just the fact
that black holds the space black has
Extra Space on the queen side and in the
center with these pawns means that if
anything it's more difficult to play
with white the balance is still there
objectively we see the evaluation bar um
it's level but in terms of finding
something for whites it's not easy at
all no natural moves yeah and magnets
down more than three minutes on the
clock after only 14 moves a few moves
ago you were talking about the white
knight minus his Knight jumping in next
to his other night are you surprised to
see it maneuver on the other side yeah
normally we see that White Knight on G3
rather than B3 uh like you say uh nearly
said Tanya
um yeah you're right the White Knight is
nearly always I think 90 of the time in
this opening on G3 so Magnus
doing some different stuff I won't say
strange different stuff yeah I'm not
sure it's working
um I I would say from the opening if we
just compare it to the other match that
these two uh two stars played in uh this
this is a success for farouza you know
he's got a very decent position I think
uh I don't think he's he's really worse
here at all he's got equality and it's
also a kind of position I think he he
probably enjoys playing all the pieces
on the board lots of tension uh and
things there's gonna be some tactics
explosions uh on the board at some point
with some exchanges or pushers so
um so I I I think it's it's gone well
for black and as you said David he's got
a four minute and increasing time
Advantage which is surprising is this a
sign that magnus's for whatever reason
not not so comfortable today I don't
know why he wouldn't be comfortable
comfortable did you just read that
comment from future chat I said that
magnus's passion was gaming chairs
collects them so he's actually brought a
house in Norway just to stock his chairs
so he's got 400 chairs already there and
he loves the ones from the next Chess
Place so he buys them off the studio
most rich people have a huge garage with
their Ferraris and you know he loves his
chairs the gaming chairs all around his
bedroom everywhere you know yeah he
loves he loves collecting chairs
apparently that's that's the rumor just
spreading that rumor
definitely not fake news though
how many chairs is that three in the
background or yeah I can't count but we
have mentioned you have been on one of
those chairs David you have had the
honor of sitting on one of those
collections in magnus's own words one of
the idiots in the background
yeah it's his lucky room he seems to
play really really well here and
meanwhile Knight to H2 retreating the
night this is a typical type of maneuver
when actually you're opening up the
White Queen to develop on the diagonal
the White Queen right often sit on F3
later the square that White Knight has
vacated but to me it looks a bit strange
to maneuver away from the center when
there's so much tension
um it feels like Magnus he's kind of
mixed and matched two or three different
plans here and usually I'm preaching for
consistency so I'm not sure I was going
to ask is that a bad idea normally
normally in chess if you stick to a plan
there is this cliche this saying which
kind of it's debatable but they say a
bad plan is better than no plan at all
as long as you stick to it but but two
plants is there anything about two
plants two plants are worse than one
place
1980 said that I think that's right no
worries one plan is better than five I
don't know but either way I mean it just
feels inconsistent you've parked one
night on one side of the board now the
other one uh further away don't try it
at home I totally agree David because
the the other night on the left-hand
side I mean you you mentioned that going
to F1 uh next to the king and this
maneuver that whites played it seems
much better if you had the other night
uh to join in because you know that
they're going to be much more powerful
together aren't they so uh so it does
does seem a little bit strange but it's
still it's still an okay position for
Magnus it hasn't gone hasn't gone wrong
yet but it's also quite interesting
because I was also completely taken by
surprise by that move but uh now that I
kind of it's on the board I'm thinking
that's quite clever again is passing the
decision to faruga does he trade in the
middle does he just connect the works
centralize and that's again a very
difficult decision to take should we
jump in and show what might happen here
what's going through farooja's mind
we've talked about a few options I
personally quite like one you alluded to
there you might could just kind of just
move the queen connect the Rooks why not
just bring your other Rook into the
center delay the tension bring all the
pieces to the party and often tactics
work in the favor of the side whose
pieces are more centralized here that
would be black especially if you can get
your Rooks both in the center together
but yeah releasing the tension also
makes some sense here especially while
the White Knight is away from the middle
of the board the only problem here is
that okay you might trade a queens and
we know about Magnus Carlsen skills in
the end game so I think stylistically
this one would be not kind of at the top
of my list and the other one which is
tempting is to gain space in the center
but here it's just a trade of Pawns and
once the white Bishop moves you do have
some safe squares no clear path forward
and actually the White Knight might
start to relocate towards some nice
outposts later on and wow he goes for
something similar right yeah he
initiates the porn trade and there you
go he believes that this particular
position is great for black he does
control the B4 Square as you've
highlighted but on the other hand
White's plan is very simple now it's
just going to be about moving all the
forces to the right side of the board
yeah if you talk about Pawn structure
here weights Pawns in the center they
kind of Point towards the right and
often uh it might sound simplistic but
if your pawns point in One Direction
that's the side you should be attacking
and uh Magnus does have this Pawn storm
idea of throwing Freddie the F1 forward
and then just kind of advancing in the
middle of the board whereas black has to
play with pieces rather than pawns and
here we see farusha relocate his Knight
he's going around towards the queen side
and it might well become a battle of
flanks Magnus is going to fight on the
king side uh farusha is going to switch
to the other side of the board where he
has some really nice juicy posts for his
Knights
really fascinating really imbalanced
decision this is why these two players
it's always fire on the board they just
never play for the draw always the most
ambitious move and do you think this is
a game looking at it that will end up
with a winner
it draws the least likely right now but
still early days of course yeah we're
only 18 moves into this uh game one
Magnus Carlsen with the white pieces uh
thinking again now what do you think
about Magnus so far today Ivanka does he
seem maybe a little bit off
um that's that's a little bit harsh I
wouldn't say that but I he's certainly
slower than he's normally been playing
normally he's like got a Time Advantage
he's very confident here you know he
Magnus is six on six and a half minutes
whereas Ali Reza has nine and a half
minutes
but okay
Magnus speeding up and relocating the
night he's not too proud to say that he
made a mistake aha
yeah often the top players they just
play Move by move they look at the
specific position even if they're not
even if their pieces landed on bad
scores previously they're happy to say
okay it might have lost uh kind of cost
me two moves here but I'll bring the
Knight back to the center and uh
meanwhile farooja a bit of a mysterious
night Retreat here we joked in previous
days night on f8 there is no mate night
on f8
what were the other Rhymes
guess no hate but what's the f8 doing
here protecting the black king but uh
maybe even fake making a gate
not too late not too late maybe he wants
to jump in
to the FourSquare that's the only thing
that I can think of oh using it as a
gate yeah yeah to improve his fate yeah
fate I don't know anymore we need help
either way it's the maneuvering phase
and I just want to mention as well here
is commentators we can only really talk
about momentum in such maneuvering
positions and
it's total opposite of the other day
where often Magnus was far far ahead on
the clock for Asia actually missed a
winning opportunity and went kind of got
outplayed because he was down to a
minute or two far far before Magnus but
here it's kind of rolled for first it
feels like definitely totally different
match these early days uh compared to uh
that previous Winner's final
it's a bit mysterious this game actually
um it's changed quite a lot I mean I I
was thinking the change in the center
personally I I quite like it for white
but White's pieces are quite clumsy here
it seems to me I mean you'd want to put
the light Square Bishop where the the
Knight is on the left-hand side I mean
this is kind of cramped right now yeah
it's a bit cramped so if you look at
White's Bishops in general they're
they're kind of like you know it's like
a traffic jam uh traffic jam of cars
there all get in the way of each other
and uh and to maneuver them to better
squares is going to take some time
um I do feel very unmagnus-like to put
his pieces on bad squares basically it
is he's got a nice well he's now
maneuvering it so the bishop is coming
around to get that Diagon on he is
opening up the rook and I think he will
get uh quite a nice position for his
pieces I mean structurally Pawn
structure because yours evaluate
position in two ways the pawns and the
pieces I quite like White's Pawn
structure
um it seems it's very solid in the
center
um I was a bit surprised by magnus's
over the night on the right hand side
because I thought he could have used the
pawn
instead there but it's uh it's really in
the balance at the moment this position
it's just very very tense and we see the
idea behind uh Ali Razor's night uh gate
um f8 can't be mates crates
um late bring it hate bring the gates I
don't know I think I've already said
that
it's a nice day date
yeah that's it we're going we're going
for the whole English
must be the the number with the most
Rhymes it must be yeah it looks that way
even though I'm struggling we can't find
a good one but there's a lot of work
just random words coming out the mouth
as usual bit uh uh for me and uh but I
mean this this it also looks alright for
black right I mean that Knight is a nice
centralized night it's uh got potential
I don't see it going anywhere at the
moment but
um I don't know which who would you
rather be here would you rather be white
or black
rugby black it's interesting because
what about you David would you oh if I
had to choose I would probably say white
but I wouldn't mind Black's position
either it looks like he's got a very
healthy position uh but I'm very much
about the long term and I'm on your side
time and just white support structure
long terms better but dynamically in
this moment it feels like Black's
reactive oh I mean that's why it's so
hard this game could really go either
way in the next few movies I know I
would kind of argue that the pawn
structure is the same yeah you know I
understand that the pawn on a C7 that
one's backward it's also on an open line
it's a Target but on the other hand the
white Pawn on D3 that's also pretty weak
as well and black has a beautiful Square
on B4 just to balance out everything and
okay well we did see the bishop zoom in
and attack The Rook because now lifted
and oh I was hoping
she has and she's also defended the
Knight on C6 so maybe alireza is setting
up the move Bishop to A6 attacking The
Rook
threats on the board of anchor it's
almost trapped it's uh looks really
active White's most advanced piece but
actually it's running out of squares if
white for example loses a move that's
just for its kind of argument's sake
with the white king in the corner then
suddenly this Rook is hit and the only
kind of retreat square is to go back
suddenly you've lost connection with
this Pawn that might be fateful later
but uh also you've kind of locked in
your own Bishop on B1 the black Knight's
gonna jump into this B4 Square suddenly
the black pieces are pouring forward
look how active these ones are just
really invading it's a problem isn't it
the whites pieces that they are just
discombobulated and
um they're just getting in the way of
each other as we said and they're you
know that is a big threat that Bishop
Basics and
um this this seems to put white under
some pressure now I mean uh they're all
on the wrong squares all those white
pieces on the queen side and uh he's got
to find a way to try and uh Freedom
somehow but not so easy to do
not so easy at all these Black Knights
are basically like The Gatekeepers they
hold together this pawn and therefore
black has more space more space to
maneuver his pieces are more flexible
and uh big big question for Magnus down
to under three and a half minutes
this is definitely turning in Black's
favor he needs to stem the momentum stem
the initiative now uh but he needs a
clever move I'm not seeing it I've got
to admit
evaluation bus still says level but that
could change dramatically in the next
turn or two if Magnus isn't accurate
here so what is going through alireza's
head right now he knows he needs uh to
win at some point today do you think
he's looking at this and thinking this
is a big chance and he has to take his
chances today I think he'll be slightly
excited he won't be carried away because
everyone knows it's Magnus Carlson
things can turn very quickly against you
um but I think you'll be looking at the
clock one eye on the clock he's thinking
this isn't the typical Magnus this is
not the Magnus we've seen throughout
this tournament and yeah he also easy
moves for black easy plan big threat
it's uh definitely pressure on white
it's also super important when you're
thinking about Chess not to let emotion
come into your assessment which must be
so difficult it is very difficult
because this is this is often a way that
I blunder because I'm like oh I'm
winning
and then what do you know I've blundered
yeah but um yeah so what what Ali Reza
will be thinking about is maybe I'm
slightly better and that's about it I
mean it sounds really darn boring but it
is the correct way to think you know
you've got to be Bruce uh what's going
to say Bruce Willis but that was not the
person I was thinking of Bruce Lee about
it you know your mind is like water
[Laughter]
yeah I like my position oh and it's
against Magnus Carlsen yeah yeah you
could you know you have to stop before
you go there exactly and I actually
remember Magnus during the commentary of
the 2022 candidate saying that Ali Reza
farouza suffered from nerves Aha and his
quote was like that dude is always
nervous
that dude
but he he's young isn't he I mean yeah
he's going to be more emotional just
just naturally yeah you can see in his
chest he gets quite excited so maybe you
can you can play against that as you say
you know just try to you know in this
position as black you would be getting a
bit excited wouldn't you I think because
you're seeing that uh you know you're
starting well look at magnus's time as
well I've just seen it tick down he has
just played Bishop Bay too I was
wondering about this if he can give up
the exchange somehow which is probably
gonna have to so this is a very
interesting move uh but that Bishop it
looks terrible at the moment but that
could be a really good piece that's your
star piece Bobby Fisher in the Royal
Lopez as David said in another day use
this bishop so well and he he was uh one
of the star world champions in in this
kind of structure and maybe this idea is
to give up the exchange David here if
Bishop A6 take the Knight or something
similar not exactly sure what but
there's a couple of options here yeah
like you say Simon this piece looks
terrible but it's about to become the
best piece on the board and I think
you're right you just start sacrificing
things just to open up this diagonal
look where all the targets are the black
king especially feels uncomfortable and
Bobby Fisher's favorite Spanish Bishop
the light Square Bishop I think will
come to life for example you could start
by hitting the black queen just to gain
a bit of time force her away and now go
for your move sacrificing and uh yes
you've given up some material Rook for
Knight that's a couple of points but
suddenly the White Knight wolves bring
into action look how things are clearing
off this diagonal and after a set of
Trades look at the bark start to zoom up
in White's favor you're hitting the
black queen and where does she go no
safe squares uh if she drops back then
she could potentially walk in some
severe trouble the pawn steps forward
and suddenly that Bishop which was
blocked just three moves ago is going to
play a key role in winning this game
suddenly the black king is
basically uh powerless to prevent this
attack so wow it's actually on the board
we're headed in this direction Magnus
has just played the movie five and I
think he's actually tricked for Russia
we said he had to be clever he invested
a lot of time there Magnus but now he's
got to go for the sacrifice if you don't
then you're simply dropping this Rook or
the pawn behind it but the sacrifice
looks powerful looks strong I mean do
you think Audi razor maybe uh got a
little you were talking about getting a
bit too excitable there and maybe at
that moment he was like wow I'm going to
win The Exchange and he played Bishop A6
very quickly because this line pretty
forcing really because Magnus couldn't
move the Rook because he loses that pawn
Ivanka point it out so
um this is getting very exciting now
Magnus sacrifice and exchange we have a
sacrifice Magnus is taking down to one
minute on the clock I was told before
this move both players were above 97 in
accuracy so they are playing some of
their best chess already yeah I mean
we're used to it at this point these uh
these players there was one game thought
yesterday the day before 99.7 accuracy
both players and uh yeah these guys
they're good they're pretty good and now
we're expecting Magnus to take in the
center and he needs to do it quickly oh
it takes the other way wow that's so
surprising yeah that's odd I mean yes
you're grabbing a pawn you're winning
some material back but we all know the
rhyme about Knights on the rim yeah
being a bit dim and Grim going
off the edge but why take that poem
rather than a nice Central Pawn because
uh maybe you want it at all right maybe
he just thought the Knight can drop back
and grab the Santa Pawn as well but
Black's night is so good in the center
it blocks the bishop why not get rid of
uh that lovely Black Knight in the
center I I don't understand that that
decision but still probably okay still
good compensation yeah but uh we see the
evaluation bar it still might be quite
promising for white if ferrugia allows
Magnus a couple of moves maybe to get
that white knight back off the edge of
the board back towards the center uh but
is there something he can do immediately
to gain an advantage to show that his
extra material counts I mean to me if I
were playing with either color I would
just say okay it's a mess it's like you
were saying earlier Ivanka with in your
head you just say I'm slightly better
here both players are just saying it's a
mess they don't know the evaluation and
yeah
what to do next
there's no easy moves for black at least
maybe that's what Magnus is banking on
Magnus under one minute I think it's
worth just you know that that's not a
lot of time in a position like this
where it's immensely complicated the
Queens are on the board most of the
pieces on the board you sack some
material uh you you know it's going to
be very exciting finish to this game
yeah definitely definitely and like you
both said is really chaotic on the board
and I was wondering what is the best
strategy here and we see alireza go for
the Improvement strategy the piece that
wasn't working is now on an open line
and perhaps The Rook will come to B2 and
attack the queen and the bishop well it
will certainly do that if it's allowed
big threat as you point out Ivanka Rook
to B2 protected by this bishop on A3 and
that would be a fork a double attack
white would lose a piece uh not actually
that easy to defend Magnus chooses to
trade Queens we know he loves an end
game but he is material down here he's
down the exchange just for one Pawn uh
so will we see a queen trade what do we
think
I mean the natural move would be to
exchange Queens then to continue that
plan Ivanka pointed out throwing The
Rook into magnus's guts there but
wouldn't it make sense for varusia to
keep the Queens on he's got so much more
time maybe it's tempting and it's
fruition style to keep the Queens on
um I'm on Simon's side I mean in general
I love my end games as well so I just
wanted Queens off the board material up
kind of helps here but there is some
argument for keeping the queen on uh you
could Retreat her possibly
yeah I'm kind of team keep the Queens on
the board I know the Queens have come
off The Rook is now under attack so will
he remove the Rook to B2 attack the
bishop
that is option one it's gonna be either
hit the Knight here or hit the bishop
and uh let's give farouza some time to
think but if he can consolidate okay he
attacks the Knight first if he can
somehow trade off another set of minor
pieces he's going to get closer and
closer to winning here as black oh so if
he can ever pick up that white a pawn uh
then I think magnus's chances will
disappear and wow look at what the
computer says oh white only has one move
otherwise the advantage grows massively
for black and of course Magnus finds it
Bishop takes Knight this was the only
way to minimize the damage but you have
parted with your beautiful light Square
Bishop we said that might become the
most valuable piece the MVP uh just a
few moves ago and now it's what we call
Superfluous nights the white Knights
kind of holding on to each other but
it's hanging by a thread here for Magnus
in less than 30 seconds on his clock
remember only three seconds increment it
is starting to look good for alireza
yeah I think I've picked black here
currently we should mention it's Knight
and two pawns for a rook so it's level
material uh in terms of points but
Black's got the bishop pair black hand
grab a Pawn on D3 I'm not sure you want
to do it now there might be some tactics
but uh yeah this one with 27 seconds
left version must be a huge favorite
is he looking at magnus's clock right
now
she'll be aware but again it's you don't
get too emotional if you stop playing on
the clock Magnus is good enough to find
the best moves even with 20 seconds on
this uh on the timer there so
yeah you don't want to get too carried
away
yeah I think there's a little rule that
um if you have a good position anyway
there's no reason to try and move
quicker to hustle your opponent but if
you're like equal or probably if you're
a lot worse then these ideas of playing
quicker trying to put more pressure on
your opponent and much more important
because you might just be able to win
the game by playing the best moves here
and uh I think that's what he's trying
to work out I mean he's got the two
Bishops he's got the two Rooks and
Magnus has only got one rook and uh it's
a very dangerous situation for mag to
see this would be a major win as well if
you win with black in the first game
this is what he needed Ali razor he
needed this win
um especially after that last match to
bring his confidence up and be big
favorite to take the first the first leg
at least yeah the position is still
pretty messy though so I'm pretty sure
that uh farouza is looking at ways to
simplify and there you go he Retreats
the bishop in order to attack one of the
knights
and the reason I say the position is
messy is because white also has a past a
pawn that could also limit the material
and uh well we see a trade
um there he comes the a pawn starts
pushing it's the only thing white can do
maybe you miss this move I mean I I
don't know yeah I mean it's quite an
obvious move but I mean uh you know this
this apron's quite strong isn't it now
it's going to tie down one of the black
Rooks this uh this a pawn you'll have to
keep half an eye on that one forever and
look at the white Rook lined up as well
against one of the black porns the White
Knight suddenly looks beautiful
I'm really surprised I've got to say it
looks like Black's Bishop power was kind
of one of his biggest assets just a few
moves ago and he's traded off a bishop
for one of those white Knights that was
hanging out uh in mid-air in the center
didn't feel necessary it feels like
ferrush has kind of taken a safety first
approach but look at the clock now it's
balancing out and you all know about
Magnus carlsen's end game skills level
end games even with material imbalances
uh can go either way in Magnus makes a
bit of a Grimace there a bit of a face
what is that about
I'm I mean I love Knight B3 here very
you know as an option but I don't know
why he's grimacing I mean uh this is
probably the best position he's had for
quite some time oh and and he plays this
move I thought he
thought there was material there for the
taking but instead he chooses to
restrain the light Square Bishop yes sir
actually taken away all of Black's best
squares for that Bishop uh Black's
Bishop wanted to kind of zigzag back
into the center onto the D5 Square to
protect uh the isolated E6 Pawn but
okay both sides going active not
materialistic at all until this move
Magnus does snap off another Pawn it's
level material yet again but uh whose
piece configuration here is going to be
better I think I would start taking
white now just feels like you're out of
danger completely and uh Black's Rooks
are disconnected that white a pawn is so
strong right now yeah and this this is
the move I I thought could be very
Troublesome for black that night coming
towards the C5 where is that seconds
it's gonna move no time at all wow with
only one second left is now in trouble
yeah and the Knight comes in attacks the
rook and Magnus is going to pick up the
E6 Pawn yep that has gone
so now he's material up he's got three
pawns and a knight just for Black's Rook
but Black's Rook is very active and it's
going to keep harassing the white Bishop
there we go the problem is the white
Bishop its diagonal is quite short it
needs to keep protecting that white
apron if you want to win this game but
you're running out of squares
maybe first has found a way to kind of
draw this and okay as I say that Magnus
doesn't care about his Bishop he counter
attacks against the black Bishop instead
is he going for the win he's going for
the win Magnus it's only Magnus here who
can really win even if the white a pawn
drops off it should still be uh drawing
for white there but okay he's got two
past pawns and a knight can he start
running with them or can the black Rook
hold them off he's hanging by a thread
here for for sure but he might be in
time
oh he wins the white a pawn
interesting ending here though so you've
got equal material uh The Rook much
better than a knight but those two pawns
a little bit dangerous I mean I I don't
think they're going to be enough because
you've only got one pass Pawn here and
that shouldn't be enough Against The
Rook you could even lose this if you
push too much as white but pretty much
all the danger is uh is with black here
and I'm not really sure where this game
turned as well I mean ferrugia I think
David pointed out
um and here we see maybe a pawn dropping
he gave up his Bishop pair and that that
that was probably the mistake made and
what can Magnus do here can he uh Pro is
pulling forwards do anything like that I
I was thinking you might as well right
and uh but it comes two postpones headed
towards the black king oh Magnus
captured that with the Knight I think
he's just trying to head it towards a
draw now I I think I think he's kind of
realized that it's not going anywhere
else and there's not enough material
here or really any Dage of either side
to to lose this one the black Rook moves
away as far as it can from the night to
avoid any forks and white only has one
past Pawn but the black Rook is very
strong here uh tying down white so
should be should be a a relatively safe
draw here we should mention if all the
pawns disappear just a rook versus
knight it is a draw and okay farushi
gives up his winning chances it's gonna
fizzle out to King versus King
everything off the board a fight to The
Bitter End it's a draw there it is game
one a draw still tied Magnus calls now
after the first game in the Grand Final
Ali reservous are looking over this why
Fosters a missed chance for him David
big missed opportunity for alarisa
farooja he had a lot more time on the
clock he had a big Advantage a material
advantage as well on the board but in
the end uh Magnus too good in the end
game and closed it out to safety and I
just want to highlight one moment where
maybe alireza missed an opportunity it
was here with white Knights not actually
being as impressive as they look I think
he could have for example dislodged one
of the white knights with uh dropping
his Bishop back he could for example
have just defended his weak Pawn in the
center but what he did giving up his
beautiful Dart Squad Bishop for one of
the knights and suddenly there was no
risk anymore for white this Pawn this
white apron was the Clincher it managed
to secure uh managed to ensure that one
of the black Brooks was passive and a
draw a fair result in the end Magnus
giving a little bit of a face after the
game ended with a draw is that shaking
of the head for Magnus Carlsen yeah
classical Magnus but it is a jewel this
first game Magnus here with the white
pieces alireza bruja will have the white
pieces in game two he has to win this
match to take it to a second match and
win the Julius bear generation cup the
final continues in a few minutes but
first a little break
foreign
[Music]
it doesn't look like much but neither
would a Sicilian Defense to the
untrained eye this is a performance
enhancer you don't see it how about now
manage your air quality sharpen your
performance change the game with air
things
[Music]
thank you
well it is all about an exciting Grand
Final today between 20 year old aloe
reservous and 32 year old Magnus Carlsen
but we're also going to be talking a
little bit about racing today and
earlier this week in the studio we were
joined by a very special guest
he is a Formula E former world champion
a United Nation Ambassador for clean air
and a Julius bear Ambassador we're so
happy to be joined by Lucas Degrassi
Lucas welcome how are you doing today
I'm very well thanks for having me
so excited to have you here with us and
I'm gonna jump straight into it Lucas
what inspired you to become an eraser uh
well I did my career as a as a normal
racing driver I went all the way from
cartoon to Formula One
um best include 413 former two uh then I
did a few races uh in endurance which
means long uh long races 12 hours 24
hours and then I helped to create Funway
because the future of the technology
that we'll see on the roads are electric
actually the present in uh in Norway is
already electric so then we decided to
create the Formula One of electric cars
which was former e uh 10 years ago and
I've been involved in followers ever
since and been racing there and the
championship is growing
um so I'm very happy where I am after a
nine Seasons racing from Ray
that's so cool and with all of this
find a way into your life
so a chess has been actually very recent
part of my life so
um we have been using the analogy that
the formula e-raced
um is a bit like Chess at 200 kilometers
per hour because you have to make a lot
of strategic decisions while driving the
car in the limit and these strategic
decisions a lot like chess like you can
for many laps during the race try to put
pressure on your opponent and try to
understand where are the flaws and where
he's doing mistakes and then in the
right moment you attack and overtake so
you need to be extremely good in
strategy during the race to be able to
succeed in formulaim and that's all due
because you have a energy management
during the race so the battery is going
down if you attack too much the battery
uses too much energy if you don't attack
uh you get attacked by others so it's
all this balance between being
aggressive but at the same time
position yourself in the right moment to
make the attack in the last few laps and
win the race Lucas we also know that
you're part of the Mensa Community uh
and I'm guessing that you do enjoy a bit
of a challenge off the track as well
because we've got something fun planned
for you
uh yeah yeah I enjoy I enjoy a challenge
and yeah I'm very competitive so I'm not
very good at chess so I get very angry
when I when I lose so uh
of course I I still have a lot to learn
and uh trying to understand how this
game goes but uh uh yeah I'm a very
competitive I'm up for a challenge all
the time yes
that's all you need for today to be
competitive because Lucas you will be
playing against our very own David
Howell and the challenge is how long how
many moves and how long can you last
against uh David uh David's here David
are you ready
hi Lucas I didn't know that I didn't
know that was a challenge nobody told me
but you know you're all about taking
those Split Second decisions on the
track uh so it's high pressure Lucas are
you ready for this one
I'm ready yes
let's do this
there is a Twist however in honor of the
fact that you are one of uh the world's
best drivers we're gonna make it fast
and furious I'm only gonna have 30
seconds on the clock and you're gonna
have two minutes so hopefully that uh
balances the odds slightly okay uh let's
do it let's do it okay we'll get the
game going now good luck I've started
really slowly here I've lost a lot of
time
symmetrical chess playing copycat here
okay I've got to go for checkmate I've
only got 20 seconds
I need to start pre-moving
hopefully I'm distracting Lucas here by
talking that's my plan
okay I've won a night but still a long
way to go whoa first check of the game
surprise me there
hitting my knight oh my god I've only
got 16 seconds
okay I'm just gonna have to attack
and okay I've won the queen here we go
okay still a long long way from
Checkmate though this is not going to be
easy at all
oh I'll take that one check
14 seconds race against the clock look
at that Focus trying to distract him but
it's not working
okay I'm taking that one
oh
maybe my slip there I'm hoping
I must let two but
okay here we go I'm just gonna get
everything off the board because I'm
panicking nine seconds
oh wait oh no my Mr mate Mr chat mate
this is going to go on much longer than
I was hoping
okay seven seconds I've got an extra
rook and two Bishops but Lucas is
defending really really well
okay that's a check
that's a check
and I think I've got him
I've caught his King in the corner
five seconds left though
where can I go here
ah sorry because I think next move it's
inevitable
or five seconds left
Checkmate is coming where can I move
here
it's not still mate luckily you do have
two pawns you can push
there we go
that is Checkmate okay good job
no good job to you too I mean you got me
down to my last five seconds and the
game did last 28 moves that's longer
than some Grandmasters have lasted so
well done what did you think of the game
um yeah I mean uh it's unbelievable how
you guys can play uh so good it's um
it's uh
like what I like what I love about Chess
you have all the information there right
so it's just a matter of uh of um
of uh understanding how the the the
probabilities and making so fast
decisions like this is for me
inconceivable like you had like 20
seconds I would not even think about
which uh which uh which pieces to move
so it's kind of this type of let's say
mental ability that you guys train your
whole life that we also do while we race
and it's um it's uh
I can imagine
that that this mental ability can relate
a lot what we do on the racetrack so
congratulations is really impressive
yeah Lucas I just want to say thank you
so much for the game and thank you for
joining us today thank you very much and
uh I hope I can uh can learn a little
bit more and improve
so that was recorded a few days ago and
good job on Lucas lasting 28 moves
remember one of the smartest men in the
world Bill Gates only lasted nine moves
against Magnus Carlson in the same time
control and well Lucas did try David's
sport here so in the next break we're
going to show you what happened when
David and Simon tried Lucas's sport
doing a go-kart
foreign
[Music]
[Laughter]
in a go-kart race between David and
Simon but now it's game two Magnus
Carlson snacking up to get his energy up
the first game was a draw and then this
one alireza will have the white pieces
so Ivanka what do you expect from the 20
year old who has to win at some point
today well here we go yeah and I'm
expecting it is gonna be a full blooded
Challenge and there we see the Sicilian
on the board and Magnus he's really
taking up the gauntlet he's saying you
know you know Ali Reza you like to pay
shop openings show me what you got
this is provocative from Magnus
yesterday we saw something similar but
uh also provocative there but uh
something with a maybe safer reputation
here it's like waving a red flag to the
ball he's basically said okay white you
take the center you take all the squares
and I'm going to try and counter attack
later this is known as one of the most
risky uh variations of the Sicilians
really exciting yeah exciting it shows
Magnus actually wants to win this uh no
solidity at all but uh farusha I think
this should be a good sign for him and
his fans uh at least now he's guaranteed
a big fight he's guaranteed at least
some attacking chances the black king
often a big Target in these types of
opening Simon are you as surprised as me
uh yeah I'm excited I mean I I Magnus
has been playing really sharp hasn't he
I mean in the previous match against uh
farooza when he had black uh he played a
line which was probably losing uh for
him in a sharp Sicilian so it's great to
see this I am I think uh Ali Razer will
be very happy to get this on the board
as well because there's Big Pawn in the
center of the board you can base an
attack around White's Knight in the
center of the board it has some juicy
squares uh it might be able to jump into
and this is just a very exciting uh
opening position uh one of the problems
that black has there is where'd you put
the king because uh if you leave it in
the middle well okay it's never safe
there if you Castle kingside uh you can
also come under a big attack so that's
uh that's what uh the problem that
Magnus has to solve here where does he
put his King and eraser can just Castle
it's easy for him to put his King
somewhere this is game two in the Grand
Final in division one earlier tonight
division two was decided Jana pomniachi
winning the match against slavon aronian
to win division two and we have some
updates on division 3 as well Sam Savion
playing
and Savion coming from the losers
bracket has been able to win the first
match to force in Grand Final reset in
division three we will follow that as
well this is game two though in division
one Grand Final with the bar in shinga
for alireza slightly slightly it is uh
inching up this is still a relatively
well-known position uh again it's kind
of provocation it's the name of the game
here Magnus now at least he has forced
the white Pawn forward to E5 the fire
Advanced spawn Simon was mentioning uh
it's normally a very kind of strong
point it is a strength but it is a
target as well and uh Magnus with this
last queen move he's saying I don't need
a castle I don't need to develop I'm
just going to hit your Pawn on E5 and
meanwhile more snacks have appeared yeah
is that a carrot yeah he loves his
carrots Magnus Yeah you mentioned the
other day that he he stopped eating or
he stops eating at like four o'clock or
something like that because he didn't
have so that's why he's got the carrots
and as soon as he had the carrot in the
previous match he uh
um he did really well he won the game so
his magic ingredient is the carrot and
uh Ali Reza jumping in with a knight to
give a check
and after it was promptly traded off
then we see Magnus step up the queen to
the C6 Square it's forming a battery to
threaten potential checkmates so that's
why alireza played the blocking move
f2f3 but this game is sharp and again
looking at the stats here I can see that
58 of the games have finished in a draw
but 25 have finished in a win for white
oh how about for black uh 17 thank you I
was gonna say save me from doing my math
stuff 17 okay so White's slightly ahead
in this position and I think we have to
jump in because the position has just
changed a lot let's show an action
replay of the just the last few moves uh
we saw here black attacking trying to
snack on this Pawn just like Magnus is
snacking on carrots right now uh this
was met with a check and don't take this
pawn it is poisoned on D6 this is
actually a recurring theme into the
current position uh this would walk into
a self pin uh suddenly the Black Knight
is lost because it cannot move uh the
queen is undefended behind it so Magnus
of course sidestepped that there's a big
big battery along this diagonal
potential checkmating threats as you
might have mentioned F3 therefore
blocking the Queen's diagonal Magnus
pushes forward the Knight is then hit
and Knight to F4 I must admit I'm out of
theory here I'm not sure exactly uh how
black proceeds next to me it looks
really beautiful for white here this is
a weak Pawn uh if white just steps
forward for example
uh hitting this porn of anchor are there
still games in this database there are
still games and basically black says you
know what I'm not bothered by materials
things I'm just going to get the king as
quickly as possible to safety castle
kingside and
after that white has a choice you can
take the pawn you can centralize the
Rooks you can even improve the light
Square Bishop okay even in this position
improving the lights go Bishop let's
just show that tactic you want to kind
of maybe zigzag over to harass the black
queen and don't take the spawn of your
Magnus Carson again it's poisoned so
many tactics here the bishop jumps out
the way with the check gaining time and
when the king reacts Queen takes Queen
actually Magnus is walking a tightrope
here but he clearly he knows what he's
doing this is a total reverse of the
previous game uh because look at the
clock times he's got 15 and a half
minutes much more time than he started
with and it is farusha who's been
surprised this is where the opening
battle we talk about it in chess picking
your openings uh you have to be so kind
of diverse with your opening choices
these days you have to be really clever
maybe he'd pinpointed that farusha
doesn't have any experience in this
position or hasn't had any games in this
line and uh Magnus I'm still not unsure
about the objective evaluation still
looks good for white visually but if he
solves his opening problems here holds
the draw without any trouble then big
success for him yeah still snacking on
that carrot Magnus cross and then do you
think it has to do with keeping his
energy up feeling that the carrots make
him lucky or do you think it's uh for
the same reason I used to eat carrots a
lot because it would give me a nice tan
maybe he's going on vacation somewhere
or something like that is that right
yeah yeah it does like it makes you go
orange doesn't it so if you eat too many
if you keep the perfect amount of
carrots it's going to give you that nice
Golden Tan so what is the perfect amount
asking for a friend I would say three a
day
you'd go Orange let's let's test it on
me I'm already orange enough thank you
so I don't need to go any more orange
I think it's the same with turmeric
isn't it as well and other things so but
um yeah I mean I think it's it is just
uh obviously to give a bit of energy in
complicated position but I am everything
David was saying there this you know it
is Theory Magnus has prepared this
position but to someone who doesn't know
this position it it looks horrible uh I
I think absolutely horrible for black
because uh it's equal material the white
porn right cutting the board in two
writing in Black's guts there in the
middle of the board that that can't be
easily taken Black's Pawn looks very
weak on F4
um white White's gonna put a rook on the
open file and um
I'm very interested to see what magnus's
idea is after this bishop D3 because uh
you you really want to know what you're
doing in a position like this because it
can go horribly wrong otherwise so what
is the idea what what what should black
do here I mean uh it's it doesn't look
nice to me you know let's consult the
Oracle Ivanka yeah no I was going to say
that um this move has actually never
been played before so I I'm just uh
relying on my own wits and I was it does
force Queen takes Pawn as Magnus has
played but this does allow the white kid
sorry the black king to get caught in
the middle of the board I was going to
ask about that black king are you 100
sure he's got a castle uh
um yeah
I mean could he Castle the other way is
he just not gonna move it now it's check
and he has to commit uh unfortunately we
can't Castle when we're in track so he
has to decide which way to go but not
attractive at all
I would walk towards the side with more
Pawn shelter probably but there we see
the natural move uh running behind these
pawns and suddenly the evaluation bar
reacts it's a massive Advantage now for
white I think just Queen E2 is one move
right I mean and this is just a kind of
a position that alireza really enjoys
playing I mean the evaluation bar
showing this is a stronger move than
Queen E2 but it's maybe you can even
swap Queens that's not completely stupid
Bishop F5 or saying that's what Bishop
B4 yeah one of these moves but it's you
don't want to be defending a really
uncomfortable position against you know
where you have no activity against
someone as uh as active as Ali Razer who
plays these positions great and as Dave
was showing here the the exchange of
Queens is actually a very clever idea so
maybe you have to go to d8 then but how
many people would put their King keep it
in the middle of the Border I guess the
c7s where is where you can you know well
he does it he does he fat he finds the
right move straight away no surprise
really uh that he finds it straightaways
that's what he does isn't he uh in this
but it still looks very scary for black
though it's still super scary you could
imagine the White Queen coming up and
kind of checking the black king on this
diagonal you can imagine certainly uh
when wherever the White Queen goes now
The Rook lining up and it's got huge
Targets on the D file uh I mean Magnus
is temporarily a pulled up but remember
it is one of these ugly doubled pawns on
the f file that double Pawn really
counts for nothing and for sure he's
happy to go into an end game just like
we showed he offers the queen trade now
I think you pretty much have to trade
Queens here as black you cannot keep the
Queens on the board with such a weak
King you will get checkmated and when
the Queens come off I guess Magnus is
banking on the fact he can defend this
Pawn but
still hanging by a thread but what do
you think about this decision to trade
of Queens I'm just asking because it
breaks one of my golden rules which is
when you're attacking the king it's a
it's normally a good idea to keep the
Queens on the board
I agree despite my love event games I
don't think I would have done this it
just feels like momentum was on white
side and also you've got to know your
opponent you're playing Magnus end games
always seem to turn on his favor but I
guess farouja here he's banking on this
position being forced and then he's
thinking maybe he's going to go horn
hunting here and still looks pretty nice
for white the same game yeah but I mean
I I I I totally agree with you saying
keep the Queens on the board would have
been much more scary and I think Magnus
would have been much more uncomfortable
uh with the Queens on the board because
you always have to watch out your king
is just more of a Target right and here
the black king could actually be quite a
nice asset because the Queens are off
the king is in the middle of the board
and yeah Ali Razer is going to win his
Pawn back
um so he still maybe has a nice position
but it's uh you know it makes it a bit
easier for black to play that Queen
exchange there's also a big threat on
the board of uh the bishop actually
coming in to take on a D7 yeah nice move
nice Sri Lanka and uh that would force
the black Bishop into a pin maybe we
just show the threat because uh Magnus
actually uh he has two dual threats to
face I think this is the Lesser threat
this Pawn is going to drop anyway so you
have to just leave it here but if for
example I try and Chase your bishop and
this would be a huge uh blunder
potentially because Bishop takes porn
would allow a pin a temporary sacrifice
next move you line up you win this
bishop back with interest and of course
we all know we're up about Rooks on the
seventh rank uh here it's all the
targets this Rook is going to Feast on
this Pawn later this Pawn later you
could even start bringing the other Rook
up to the seventh Rank and all these
black pawns will be targets
and this would just be game over so he
has to deal with this uh Magnus Carlsen
right now Bishop takes Pawn here I'm not
sure how to deal with that I wanted to
move my king out the way off the back
rank you always want to connect your
Rooks and kind of bring them to open
files later but again you walk into a
pin Rook takes pawn and suddenly this
bishop is pinned meaning that this Pawn
is still threatened it's a really kind
of clumsy configuration here for black
it's really flimsy it could collapse at
any moment but he's played fast up until
this move Magnus Crossing is it possible
he has some sort of a plan
with this uh strange situation his King
all open yeah I think he believes in his
drawing chances here just because it's
reduced material and he's never never
scared of an in-game Magnus Carlsen but
yeah it doesn't show us a much kind of
ambition as I was praising for him for
earlier I was saying it's a provocative
opening you're saying come at me come at
me and then you'll counter attack later
but there's no counter attack here it's
just black playing for a draw
am I wrong I don't know yeah it feels
like black is just playing for a draw
and it's difficult to find a move I mean
the most logical one is the king
stepping up to C7 I mean you could try
rookie eight trying to make some
exchanges I mean something like that
would make sense and the more PC
exchange maybe the closer to a draw you
can get
um that's probably the move I'd play
just bring the brook to the center and
uh you know at least activate one of my
pieces
um if I can play that um maybe make some
sense here uh I mean it's it's a strange
situation you can see him on the camera
yeah now finally he kind of reacts to
the situation it seems strange I mean uh
but I wonder how narrow is the path
because we see the evaluation by a
slightly wise favor I'm just curious
yeah maybe we can get the stockfish
engine suggestions up on the screen how
many moves here does black have to kind
of keep the game roughly in the balance
oh look at that White's Advantage grows
massively if you don't find the move
Pawn to A5 and that's not 100 obvious we
were saying that the black king moved
the second best move according to the
computer there that's the more natural
for a human but suddenly White's
Advantage grows to over plus one and
some middle games plus one is tolerable
manageable but in an end game plus one
is very significant uh and yeah Pawn to
A5 the whole idea is that the black Rook
on A8 will activate it will defend
things uh kind of by moving to the A7
Square the A6 Square that's not obvious
Simon no I mean the problem with like a
move natural move like rookie 8 which I
which looks very human is that the
Tactical threats actually remain after
White's Rook just wins the pawn back so
uh this position there's Rook takes
Bishop as a big fret and uh uh you know
you even though you're in an ending this
is really really horrible your king
can't move because the ideas we've shown
before white can even start moving the B
Pawn up the board so A5 is not an easy
move to find Magnus will find it I bet
you anything
um
kind of regret saying that if you did
it's more of a bluff but the idea they
were confident I said it would
accomplished exactly even if I didn't
mean it
um yeah I think A5 at least tries to get
as David says the rook in the corner up
as a defensive piece but it also stops
his B4 ideas uh which we um we we saw
might be very scary if White's able to
get them in but it's uh yeah I I think
now the more I'm looking at this
position uh the more I'm actually
realizing that Magnus could be in a lot
of trouble and he's in a tough spot here
he's got to find this very difficult
move I mean you're getting attacked in
the center so you move a Pawn on the
side of the board that's not very
natural is it
um he'll find it though any yeah
thinking for almost five minutes now
that's a long time to think in this time
control that's a long time okay will he
find it come on who who there's a bet in
the air after you vanco you're the queen
of predictions you know that on this
show yeah I think he'll find a process
of elimination because he'll he'll look
at the king stepping forward and he'll
go I really hate that and you know
necessity is the mother of invention so
yeah I'm gonna say he's gonna fight it
okay
I don't know it was tough I think you're
right Ivanka process of elimination
that's what all the top players do they
calculate calculate calculate and if the
lines aren't working out in their favor
they continue to look for Alternatives
and he was looking at the king moves The
Rook moves Simon mentioned all of those
and they weren't working out for black
your king was walking into the firing
line and eventually you stumble across a
move that does survive that doesn't lose
immediately or doesn't uh kind of worsen
your position and you have to play it so
um that's how often the top players find
the best moves in here okay big threat
Rook taste Bishop is threatened due to
the pin on the defiles of the black king
has to evacuate and uh here we go the
black king is walking but nice defense
there for Magnus Carlsen he has found
the only way to keep the disadvantage to
a minimum and uh okay what next for
white the problem is for faruga he was
playing for tactics now he has to switch
gears and maybe play more strategically
white does have the better Pawn
structure if you look at the left half
of the board uh the queen side there
white has three connected pawns black
has two isolated pawns so three versus
two majority on the other flank the king
side here it's four versus three in
Black's favor but two double pawns so
the four doesn't really make a great
impression against the three and he's
trading off Bishops interesting yeah I
mean I guess Black's Bishop is a great
defensive piece I mean the this move is
trying to keep the pressure against the
the pawn in the middle of the board
which the bishop is defending
um but uh it it is double edged as well
because I mean if the bishops come off
Black's majority on the king side of
Pawns poor majority becomes a lot more
dangerous so uh
um black can also Magnus now can get
that rook in the corner and swing it
across at some point to try and activate
it so this A5 me was was very clever
yeah very otherwise he'd have been in
serious trouble but he always finds
these moves when he when he needs to
that's that's why he's the best player
in the world I really do think that
Magnus needs to start activating his
pieces now is not the time for being
passive at all if you is there a trap if
you take this bishop I was going to say
maybe the white Rook gives you a check
uh White doesn't really want to take
back the bishop with a pawn because
suddenly this Pawn in the center is
actually isolated and weak but if you
give a check you dislodge the black king
you force the black king to commit if it
goes back to the back rank we know that
that's not a great place for the king
we've seen that already this game but
suddenly a problem of two pawns being
attacked and Magnus of course he doesn't
make this mistake he defends the bishop
with his Rook but the evaluation bar
still slightly uh heading up now in
White's favor I'm expecting her the
bishop to take this bishop maybe you can
delay that uh that tension you can just
improve the white king you can I don't
know push a pawn but Magnus he's really
really on the back foot here lower on
time and every move notice how he's got
to find one of only two moves or forced
moves just to stay alive in this game
and it's still not pleasant yeah both
games he's been on the back first
exactly and first one you said it was a
missed opportunity for farouza David
will this one be as well if he doesn't
win it yes uh earlier I was talking in
the day about the longer the match goes
the more fruja will kind of fancy his
chances if the scores are still balanced
but the way the first two games have
gone if he doesn't win either of them if
this one ends up as a draw then he'll
start I think he'll start to get
frustrated I think it's only natural
only human to get frustrated definitely
because you don't get many chances
against Magnus so we should expect Ali
reservous to really fight for a win in
this game now he has the white pieces
and he's definitely up on the clock
again Magnus Carlsen in trouble
yeah in trouble I don't know with best
play maybe you can hold the draw here it
is Magnus after all but I definitely
expect furition he's found so many
testing moves and yeah uh a lot of the
top players they've played strategically
sound moves but he always has a kind of
tactical idea behind everything he does
first he kicks the black king back makes
a lot of sense he protects his Bishop in
the center as well what next I mean
Magnus being clever with his King
Retreat as well tucking it to safety he
could have stepped it forward but the
king would have been a Target there I
think for richer has to also now
consider what Magnus is gonna do like
Magnus has a natural Target he's going
to put a rook on the open line and
Target the B2 Pawn so I think if uh
farouza takes some Care on that side and
tries to kill that activity before it
even manifests then furusia will have a
very pleasant advantage
Magnus leaning back he looks pretty
happy with uh that last couple of moves
the Bishops are off the board again that
was the most natural move for farouza
but uh he had maybe there's just no way
to kind of break through right now it
looks so tempting to put a white Rook on
the seventh rank we talked about that
being the dream location seventh heaven
yeah for a rook but maybe a rook trade
will happen there should we uh dive in
because I'm kind of excited about that
Rook move the most natural move at least
now I think ferruges plan is to drop the
Rook into D7 a killer threat now if both
Rooks land on the seventh rank that's
just game over uh this Pawn will drop
then this Pawn will drop then the H1
will drop as well uh but okay black can
try and trade off Rooks and Go Active
what is happening here this is based on
the tactic that if a rook trade does
happen white can actually win a pawn
it's now three versus one on the queen
side but the problem is you're just too
late one move too slow black gives a
check and then another check and takes
on B2 and blackstroke is so active this
should be a draw cutting off the white
king
and this is on the board I think Magnus
does he need to find this move or at
least one of these Rook trade ideas he
has played it of course he'll find the
best move if there's only one and
suddenly the black Rook is getting
active
just in time for Magnus Carlsen yeah I I
think Magnus just has enough activity
here I mean you can try uh to go Rook E7
here as well maybe we could show that
line because obviously this is uh I
think nimsovich was the first person to
write about having a rook on the seventh
Rank and uh I guess Magnus can exchange
one Rook off and again activate his Rook
maybe in a different way though go Rook
B8 attacking that pawn which if you you
have to really defend with something
like B3 and there could be a lever like
A4 now and this kind of move A4 will be
key to the defense without this move
you'll be in a lot of trouble because
you wouldn't be able to get your Rook
active but the most important thing in a
in a rook and pawn ending is to is to
get your Rook active and you can see in
an ending like this the black Rook gets
extremely active and he will have no
trouble uh drawing a position like this
at all so so it's not clear and the live
board this has happened Rook D7 Rook d8
um so it's not clear how
farooza can keep an advantage now
because all of these lines a black Rook
is getting into White's position and as
soon as that happens I feel Black's
going to be active enough the
yeah you could go Rook takes A5 here
that's quite funny
maybe that's a very strange move
um I think it's a tactic like you
pointed out the other day you rank in
this one uh but it probably doesn't work
here maybe it worth a try yes so let's
jump back in actually to show this
because it is really flashy and it
wasn't on my radar I've got to say I
wonder if it was on magnus's Rook takes
A5 ignoring the threat on the rook and
look at the standoff this um kind of
standoff between the two Rooks here no
matter which Rook black takes white will
take the other one for example if you
take this Rook the other Rook will drop
if you take this Rook the other Rook
will drop with check and I actually
think it's the other one you have to
take you have to take on A5 here and
after this check the black king moves
next move at least you can snack on this
one
and uh is there a huge difference a huge
difference if you took the other Rook
actually then I think it's losing for
black on the spot because suddenly after
this check you're not threatening uh the
white rook and white will have time to
connect three and uh long term these
will win the game
so yeah it's a big big difference and I
think this would be clever for malaria
at least if he wants to give magnesium
always on the board yeah I spot Simon
well I mean I think he has to but again
it does seem like magnus's Rook is still
going to be uh active enough here
because white cannot defend uh the A2
Pawn wherever white moves The Rook the
black Rook is going to come and take on
A2 and is there any way uh Addy razor
can keep the game winning chances alive
here uh because b2's on pre and the
black king is starting to get very
active as well I mean that black king uh
can come via the diagonal towards
White's pawns as well and uh you know
you have to be careful not to allow such
things as that so I think it's still
okay for Magnus here yeah but he's
defended so well hasn't he and uh did
Andy race really have any big chances
though we were saying it's a missed
opportunity but where where was his
missed opportunity it's like you know I
I don't think there was any missed wins
and such were there no I don't think so
but I mean if I'm gonna
pinpoint one moment where I think that
alireza could have improved it's perhaps
avoiding that Queen trait
but then again I'm not going to be too
critical of it because this was a really
tempting ending to get into and the move
A7 A5 was such a difficult move to spot
and calculate
and yeah it's an interesting position
here as well and I was wondering whether
Harry Reza's Rook cured to get up to
some Mischief there on the right side
but uh Magnus cool as anything just
simply goes no I'm gonna capture the
pawn this is probably the only way to
try and play for a win that keep playing
for a win and this is great to see Ali
razor do this because uh he's brave
because he's going to get quite an
unbalanced position now
um but yeah he's still playing for the
win nice yeah still playing for the win
and this Balancing Act Magnus has just
having a weak King in the opening middle
game but then it becomes such a strength
in the end game because it never castled
and it's centralized I don't think
anyone else in the world can get away
with that and uh maybe steinits would
have been proud of steinits King but uh
anyway all these checks now forcing the
white king away uh this is in order to
tie down the white Rook to White's pawns
on the second rank uh the problem is the
only way to evade the checks to keep the
game going to keep the winning chances
alive is to walk away with the white
king and then the Black Brook has uh
serious threats against the White bones
Magnus looks pretty chilled you could
say and also the time situation means
the elevator will not be confident here
about his chances of converting
well converting what at this point it
might just be equal this end game Magnus
has survived the West
down to under two minutes on the clock
is there any chances for Magnus to win
this game or is that hope just uh not
there you never know I would say if
alireza is able to pull the brakes now
and Body Language looks like he's ready
to take the draw this is gonna fizzle
yeah
okay he trusts magnus's end games there
so then they have got a draw so yeah
well defended by Magnus say he's he was
under pressure throughout but uh held on
to the draw
game two is a draw still tied after two
games in the Grand Final Ali wears of
Russia he has to win a game at some
point to have any hopes of winning the
Julius bear generation cup and this game
another game with chances for him David
another game with uh real chances for
alireza and the one big debate here is
whether he should have traded Queens
Magnus Carlson had a very weak King as
black caught in the center and here
elevator tried to transform the nature
of the position by playing the move
Bishop to F5 If instead maybe he'd move
this queen for example to E2 we would
have seen a big attack against the black
king and who knows the game might have
ended differently instead after the move
Bishop F5 very attempting as well we saw
a queen trade and uh it was this
position Magnus found the key defense
the only move to minimize the damage
Pawn to A5 and later as we saw the game
did fizzle out to that draw Magnus he
was snacking on carrots during this game
this was his reaction when it ended with
a draw
he seems uh quite chill today Magnus
Carlsen they are tied alireza and Magnus
after the first two games
look at that two Jewels so far two rapid
games to go and if uh well both of them
are tied then we're gonna see
Armageddon in this match here in the
Grand Final Magnus Carlsen will have the
white pieces in game three the final
continues in a few minutes first a
little break
[Music]
thank you
September Bots are here and it's time
for a Monumental Clash
Barbarian might not Crush you on the
board but he certainly can Crush you
with the board speaking of crushing this
giant is a living Siege Tower usually
found in groups goblins are fond of
sharp pointy objects and other people's
pieces
the battleheart in Valkyrie might give
you a game once she's done arm wrestling
a Golem
this hog rider and his Noble Steed might
give you a headache or two skeletons
adore her those fear her you'll need to
bring your A-game if you want to be this
witch yes that probably is a rabbit up
his sleeve or a huge Fireball with your
name on it we hear Wizards are pretty
good at chess
not just a killing machine Pekka loves
tiny butterflies but you're probably not
a butterfly so watch out
the Archer Queen thinks highly of
herself and for good reason she is a
skilled tactician deadly opponent and
your worst nightmare
play them all on chess.com
he blundered his Queen
music
oh my God
move quickly oh
my gosh
Gmail chest is coming to chess.com
enchant your pieces with one of two
spells jump or freeze players start with
two jump spells and five free spells
which we charge after five moves you may
catch your spare whenever you wish
before making a regular chest move jump
is a spell cast to one square wherein if
there is a piece on that square other
pieces can jump over the Charmed piece
the freeze spell is cashed over a three
by three square area and the pieces in
this area are temporarily Frozen in
place
to defeat your opponent
keyword supercell and chess.com have
cooked up in our new variant spell chess
dropping on September 1st
think you know who will take this year's
speed chess championship title the SCC
field includes reigning champ Hikaru
Nakamura World Cup Victor Magnus Carlson
jscc winner gukash D and the world
champion himself ding Loren it's a crazy
exciting field and you can now submit
your predictions for how this tournament
will unfold for the chance to win
Diamond membership use exclamation point
fantasy in chat to learn how and hurry
bracket submissions close when the first
match of the SEC begins on September the
4th
join chess kit for the highly
anticipated conclusion of the 2023 youth
speed Chess Championship September the
6th candidate Master Aaron Mendes goes
head to head with Antoni radzinski for
the crown with fun Master Mike and
Friends covering the action over at
twitch.tv forward slash chess kid use
exclamation point yscc in chat to learn
more
after two games in the Grand Final but
now they are fast they are Fierce they
are without fear of course I'm talking
about David Howell and Simon Williams
who will win when those two meet each
other on the go-kart track
[Music]
welcome to go karting myself and Simon
are pretty nervous right now it's well
known that grand Masters are terrible
drivers Simon are we gonna survive this
I think it's gonna be interesting David
I think you might have a bit of a weight
Advantage here going on I can't beat
David at chess so I've got to try and
put my foot down at the go-karting we'll
see what happens oh God it's quite scary
yes
if you hit that hard as well you're
probably gonna have yourself up that
badly yeah
I'd imagine you know I remember when I
was a child like I got traumatized I
kept hitting there yeah yeah yeah yeah
I'm quite scared bro I'm just gonna take
very easy to start with and nice and
chilled I think is the window
oh no
good luck so Andrew mate
[Music]
I hate you
foreign
[Music]
[Laughter]
laps
eight
[Music]
I say fast he's too good I'm gonna catch
him
it's too quick okay I'll sing this no I
just did stop breaking
on I can catch him I can do this you can
do this day come on dude
let's put off the break that is where is
he oh my God
[Applause]
oh
where is he
okay he's stuck yeah I'm coming I'm
coming for you oh
laughs
[Music]
stole again please do the safe
stop stalking me
okay
[Music]
amazed
oh come on
[Music]
I'm so close now
Victory Sweet Victory that's my crowning
Glory my finest hour but I was a bit
dirty I made him cry
it's gonna kill me
oh my God
I can't believe I lost you David
unbelievable unbelievable you're so much
faster than me I know it seems to be
going right until I crashed I think I
raced like I played chess a little bit
uh a little bit risky I couldn't get the
bloody reverse button to work I think my
new profession is professional go carter
um I tried the chess it didn't stick
but I was intense and congratulations
David Howell uh the champion thank you
but I was a bit dirty
just like your chest you know so I'm
gonna do anything you can to win wow new
profession as I said yeah we were
actually saying that like I don't know
if anyone's played Mario Kart but I used
to I used to love Mario Kart and uh
David's like the mushroom and I'm I'm a
bit more like Bowser
trying to squeeze on fruit but uh it was
it was loads of fun though great fun
yeah I was terrified I've got to say the
best day ever really yeah genuinely it
was really good fun and you seemed like
you actually had some skill in it Simon
before yeah yeah um yeah I haven't done
it for like probably I don't know 25
years but it was yeah it was great it
was like a bit of speech so uh love to
do it again yeah it's just uh I'm gonna
beat you next time we're always talking
about it well we talk about other sports
as well were you able to use any of the
chess skills David here uh just the
dirty skills any trick to win it's all
about winning right it's all about
winning you said it it is all about
winning Magnus crawls and with the white
pieces here this is game three in the
Grand Final and Oliver he needs to win
at some point moves are coming out
really fast now moves are coming out
fast and this is the first new move of
the day uh at least in terms of this
individual battle the opening battle
earlier Magnus went for a really slow
approach and it really backfired for
Russia had a Advantage as black so this
time instead of the timid D3 he brings
his Knight out and uh this leads to a
totally different uh type of animal
still a Spanish opening of course but it
has forced verusia to think
so surprised the name of the game in
this one yeah they mean Magnus and and
alirez had a bit of time there to to
work out uh what to do and clearly
Magnus wasn't happy with the way the
first game went and he probably wasn't
happy the way the last game went so he
hasn't got an initiative or any chances
to win so far so there's a big
Improvement for Ali Razer on the past
games but as you mentioned this night
coming out is quite a bit slower I'd say
um this one or you're going for more
Central uh control straight away with
that knight uh looking looking towards
the D5 Square yeah I'm still bitter
about that go-kart I know so David
blocking me the car not working oh dear
hashtag sorry not sorry
we're doing it again that little bump at
the end that was that was an accident
because I bribed them beforehand to uh
Tinker with the car but I don't think
I've ever met anyone who loves winning
as much as David oh he's yeah I have
played background with you
anyone other than me problem is I never
win I think you beat me in background
[Music]
what can we do to build Simon's
confidence you guys
um yeah we'll find something yeah I
reckon we need battle go-karting so I
don't know what that means but something
involving like clubs I think
I'm angry at all
send in your challenges next time uh for
the next show yeah we need ideas we need
ideas David investor Simon that's
actually a good uh series I want to see
that yeah
test boxing yeah
meanwhile a couple of moves here White's
Bishop has been kicked back the Spanish
bishop and fruition has Castle still
nothing changing uh nothing too dramatic
at least and Magnus the first to pause a
bit surprising because he was the one
who chose this uh some kind of sub
variation of the royal Lopez that he's
the first to think but there we go D3
and
now it might take a similar nature to
the previous game but at least white
tonight is more active than it was
and uh Magnus I wasn't 100 sure but it
looked like he was resting his eyes I
wouldn't say sleeping but he was resting
his eyes a few minutes ago it doesn't
look as energetic as we're used to
seeing from him do you think the latest
start today all the games began uh two
hours later than usual do you think
that's going to affect the players yeah
maybe I mean it may just need more
carrots as well right so uh get the
carrots out but it does look a bit tired
yeah you're right though David I hadn't
really thought about it but normally
when you get yourself into a rhythm I
mean in over the board chess tournaments
you usually play like at 2 p.m 3 P.M in
the afternoon and they always hold the
last round at like 11 or 10 a.m yeah and
you're like why why are you doing this
to us you kind of kill the Rhythm we got
ourselves into a routine chess players
at tournaments love the routine because
we just need that thing to rely on also
we're superstitious creatures yeah and
uh I heard a story that
David I tell it to you yes please about
David and superstitions
[Music]
well well one of my friends one of our
friends went to dinner with him and he
won the next day so after that he made
her go to dinner with him every night
that just sounds like an excuse me the
crafty tactics I know his dirty tattoos
it's like oh you have to come to doing
me again I'm like yeah yeah yeah yeah
purely innocent trust me
are you all quite superstitious
very okay
yeah I mean still I saw a magpie magpie
on the way here and I have to salute
magpies as I see him this is uh but yeah
don't look at me looking crazy I'm not I
speak to the birds
no I do it's like you're supposed to
salute one Magpie two's good luck but
one is bad luck so you gotta give a
little salute I never knew that one for
sorrow two for Joy that's right three
for a girl yeah see David knows that the
other day yeah he knows he's older
you've got to say hijack every time you
see them yeah I still do that
and we see Magnus now grabbing a pawn
David so yeah but it was Ali Raza that
uh with his Knight foray to the edge of
the board trying to hunt down the bishop
gives up the pawn
yeah I was saying that we're not weird
but this is a weird decision from Alaris
he's given up a pawn and this type of
idea is very well known in this opening
uh Magnus himself has given up uh Pawns
in the martial attack and various other
kind of branches of the Marshall uh we
saw that in his world championship match
against an apartment issue for example
but here it doesn't strike me as being
too convincing because black is unable
to break up in the center in one go and
we see the evaluation bar really react
uh if farusha hits freestyling and has
given up a pawn then he's gonna really
hope that objectively uh it is merited I
simply thinks that white can there we go
Retreat the Knight and
where's the conversation he needs the
bishop pair to start working here that's
the main competition when you give up on
as black in the Spanish opening and
blacks Bishops don't make a very
impressive uh kind of uh site here it's
really surprising to me
we do have a result in division three
remember Jana pomniacci has already now
won division two and division three is
now already uh also decided that one
went to a reset between Sam Savion the
the American and chakra two very
exciting and entertaining players it
went to Armageddon and with the white
pieces young Sam sebian was able to Win
It to Win division three and five
thousand dollars so congratulations to
him
and is that the second time some
sevillans won division three now
I think it might be he's been in second
finals about being kamsky was it and
possibly one of them but yeah he's even
played praga earlier in the season and
also division two last time in the
finals he lostovich there but he's the
kind of king of Knockouts I wouldn't be
surprised if he's played some of the
most uh well the most games in the tour
this season should actually check that
yeah I'm Savion another young one
obviously we are talking about
Generations he is one of the Young
Americans what do you see for his future
eweka Sam is a great player they're a
he's super serious about his chess I
mean
he's also as you can see by his
performance and online chairs also
extremely talented he's got tough nerves
and I think that he is gonna get better
and better and I think his aim is to get
into the American Squad which is no mean
feat right when you have Fabiana caruana
Lavon aronian love um
Dominguez and I can go on and on Wesley
so of course
and that definitely was a match of
generations in division three with Mom
dioro at 38 years old would you also say
this is a match of generations otherwise
of Russia at 20 Magnus Carlsen at 32 is
that two different Generations
feels that way Magnus grew up when
computers still weren't that strong and
alireza I mean part of his development
part of the reason he rose up through
the rank so quickly is because he was
able to play a lot online he was doing
that all the time training online
definitely a clash of styles Generations
everything and alireza farouza told us
when he was answering a question who was
his uh who he found inspiring when he
was growing up he said that he learned
chess in 2012 and Magnus became a world
champion
2013. yeah I just can't believe how he
got so good in 10 years I mean eight
years he was world number two right in
eight years of picking up the game I
mean that must be unheard of I mean
incredible yeah that must mean he has
it's some incredible talent for the game
an incredible mind yeah yeah I mean
that's very special I mean uh I don't
know anyone else who's done that
especially in modern day chess to to
become that good because the amount of
hours you have to put in just to
memorize the opening variations is is
phenomenal and uh you know so yeah
really really amazing talent just to be
able to do that and I mean going back to
to the game as well I mean I I I'm
struggling
to I understand what Black's idea is I
mean the only
concept I can think the black's trying
to do is that he sacrificed his Pawn to
play D5 at some moment and open up his
light Square Bishop
um this is the only uh idea I can see
but I just don't believe it I just don't
believe this Pawn sacrifice is enough
and it goes D6
and I'm like I'm just uh I'm I'm really
I I'm not understanding this Pawn
sacrifice because you you shouldn't give
away pawns against the best player in
the world
um so what's he saying David I haven't I
don't think he has seen the kind of
sufficient compensation here for regime
he's banking on long-term prospects of
his Bishop pair but I'm in agreement
here if you could play the move D5 and I
think it's the move you wanted to play
uh without allowing white to bypass that
pawn and advance in the center then
maybe some compensation if we show uh
something like this we see the
evaluation bar really drop uh suddenly
black is actually doing very well
because the bishop and queen battery
along this light Square diagonal would
provide full compensation but uh the
problem is that white can simply play
the move E5 and you're forced to retreat
with this Knight you're forced her to
some bad squares Sonny White can step
forward in the center black has weak
pawns here especially on D5 these
Bishops are dead they are not playing
any role and look at what Magnus is
trying to do in the game position uh for
Russia just Advanced one square and
Magnus is doing the exact same thing
he's trying to render these Bishops
passive uh for eternity he's just played
the move C4 and we know in open
positions Bishops thrive in close
positions block positions it's the
knights and here White's Knights look
beautiful uh if black
cannot break with D5 and it looks
impossible for the near future then
long-term white just is going to I mean
slowly get ready and at the right moment
utilize this extra pawn and games will
favor white middle games will favor
weight if you take on passant of this as
if this Pawn just moved once then white
is going to do the same thing next move
he'll push again and lock down the D5
break forever and uh bear in mind on
poisson is a one-time offer
should he take it because after all he
has the bishop pair it's an open
position maybe the pawn on B3 could be a
weakness
true you can only take this uh Pawn now
otherwise it's uh bypassed you for good
and uh White will play this move next
you're mentioning your maker that this
Pawn is a bit backward uh potentially a
Target the one downside here is that you
have given the white Bishop a beautiful
diagonal to sit on as opposed to kind of
not touching that pawn structure but at
least in return yeah maybe you can
Target this Pawn uh so I I don't see any
compensation for black for being a pawn
down in any of these lines at all
I mean I know he's got two Bishops David
but like he can't get them open right so
uh
um I mean this is Ali Ray's though he's
very very uh he takes risks he's a very
exciting player not many players would
even think about giving a pawn up like
that so you've got to give him credit
but it does backfire occasionally maybe
in I've got a horrible feeling it might
backfire here yeah I mean if you pick up
a black porn that's off the board now
just put it on the E6 Square you would
say it's a level position it's a normal
position but uh black is essentially a
pawn down and really hard to come up
with the plan it's not as if you're
doing too much on the queen side you're
not breaking through that so blocked
the black light Square Bishop which is
the only unchallenged piece
should be playing a better role but it
can't go any get anywhere simply yeah
very confusing it is confusing to me as
well I mean the only thing that I can
see is to do what Ali Rez is doing which
is to relocate the bishop onto the long
dark diagonal and then just pick up a
knight from F6 and take it on an odyssey
around the board to see if it can land
on either E5 or D4
yeah that is so long and it's not worthy
of a pawn yeah maybe it's some
compensation though I mean some but it's
not enough for a pawn and you know
White's got a lovely Square there as
well and we see in exchange and there's
another Square for the white knight uh
being vacated by that last poor move of
whites and uh I think black's gonna have
to swap his Bishop off when that Knight
comes around C4 I would imagine now
playing quickly all of a sudden you know
I think Magnus has really woken up and
it's because of this golden opportunity
he's been kind of gifted here uh just a
free porn a present there and it's a
really kind of perked magnus's uh
interests here and look at this not just
to see blocked up the black darts go
Bishop but there's a key Target I just
want to highlight your maneuver there
Simon I think it's incoming this is a
backward Pawn after all the base of the
pawn chain is always the weakest and
Knight back to D2 Knight to C4 Knight to
hit this ball and that would be disaster
what to do totally and also just to kind
of reinforce that this is a standard
maneuver when white has a Pawn on D5
so it will be easy for Magnus to see
that move
it's difficult to actually come up with
a move for alireza
unless he's gonna just initiate the
chaos button and just uh push pawns
explode open in the center yeah that's
exactly what I was thinking I would
recommend that you thank you because
like I mean there's a little analogy I
think that everyone can play play by and
that is it if you've got a bad position
he does he's a pawn down against a great
player uh you might as well complicate
it as much as you possibly can even if
it gets worse at some point because uh
you know by adding that Randomness to a
safe situation you give your opponent a
chance to go wrong so I maybe this idea
is worth a punt we say is on the board
he's punting as we say punting away
gambling gambling hustling is my word
hustling that's right yeah like I did on
the uh race track oh stop it David
if only my car worked properly I just
broke down but it didn't break down
I didn't I didn't know where the right
pattern was to reverse
no one told me so I was sitting there
thinking what do I do oh look where's
the reverse it's not on the stick
there's no stick it's like so it took me
yeah I was a bit slow there I like how
you were trying to get there
body weight yeah to try and move it
around I thought I've got a bit of
disadvantage on the straights but if I
throw my midsection into it I might put
a swing around the corners that was my
tactic and even with two stops it
super close it did yeah he drives like a
granite you know it's no surprise it'll
be safe around corners yeah he's like an
old woman it's like he's racing away
he actually to be fair he got much
quicker and slow and steady wins the
race yeah just like interesting are you
known for that around your friends David
to be a slow driver maybe a safe driver
safe safe is the right word exactly and
uh meanwhile Magnus Carlson's Bishop was
forced to reverse that forced uh to
retreat back to E3 and no reverse gear
here for faruga anymore because he has
to Simply go forward it's all about
speed it's all about uh yeah using that
body weight using the pawns pieces to
try and uh bully white backwards but G4
I'm assuming this will be captured
what's Magnus thinking about here uh
maybe he just doesn't want the black
Bishop to Sprint to life
I have to say I am waiting for the right
moment tonight to say the magical words
quite far off there
is this looking really good for buying
this Carlson it's looking very very good
he's still a pawn up and this time with
a strategically winning position uh we
say that because white has the extra
space in the center all of Black's pawns
on the dark squares will be weak For
Eternity Black Star Square Bishop blocks
but dynamically
okay I wouldn't trust the bar 100 yet
because uh in human terms there might be
one chance for farrugia to get back and
look at the bar it's his hair drops
I think I I was wondering if you click
on Knight H4 and G3 and just try to
Queen H5 and hold it hold uh hold the
light squares there because this this
pin is is really really horrible isn't
it I was even tempted to maybe not even
not age four but something just yeah
thing like my age four and then after
Pawn takes porn you know it just
go forth and uh do your worst I wasn't
even thinking porn takes born
or maybe even the queen coming in just a
fun fun
yeah looks like a very active play there
was possible for Magnus Queen to H5
looks very strong here but uh instead he
played the safer move uh safe isn't
always the best uh taking taking and
this pin he ran out of it but this has
come at the cost of shattering his pawns
here uh Magnus Carlson and look at this
furosha is trying to step forward is
trying to attack and Magnus meets that
by a simple King Shuffle
it's not nice moving the king like that
I think this randomizing idea that uh
farooza has used of just going for it
has worked very well here it's actually
now a free result game because the black
queen can fly in Black's Bishop is good
and there's some pressure here surely
much better than it was
definitely do you think this uh will be
like a story of our race a slow start
from farrugia and then yeah touch it
sorry I'll stop bringing it
the reverse button he can't move the
pawns backwards no reverse no reverse so
you know you can only go forwards
actually thinking about it if white just
takes the time out let's say I play a
really kind of passive move just to
defend this Pawn will black consider
potentially kicking this bishop
evaluation bar doesn't necessarily
improve but kicking this bishop and how
is this bishop ever getting in the game
White's Bishop now that's a good
question it can never move but that's
true that's a big downside to the
position but on the other hand the king
will have a super safe home on E2 and
then the Rooks can join the fun
getting sharp it's getting complicated
your catchphrase might come in handy a
bit later Kaya this one could certainly
swing either way now I'm waiting for my
moment so I have to say Frugal he is uh
down on the clock as well under five
minutes now Magnus Carlsen has more than
eight minutes and it is pressure on for
alireza he needs to win a game
to be able to win the Julius Spirit
generation cup oh Magnus plays a move I
said a passive uh move that nobody
really wants to play but he just uh he
just defends his B2 pawn and now big
moment does farouza close it up lock in
that white Bishop but at the cost of
some dynamism or does he find something
a bit more aggressive I think as you
said earlier David fruge is the kind of
player who likes to keep it fluid keep
it Dynamic and um that that move locking
down the bishop looks really interesting
but maybe he'll keep it as I don't
expect him to play here I expect him to
keep it a bit more flexible if he can
improve his pieces somehow maybe he can
get his Rooks to a better Square Rook f8
rookie eight uh and instead he's he's
decided just to open it up Queen F3
maybe he's going for mate checkmate
doesn't it end the game it doesn't end
the game and as we've seen even the
great Magnus Carlsen is not immune to
the effects of Checkmate this is looking
really scary if I was white here I'd be
uh I'd be terrified actually so uh with
the queen coming to F3 or something yeah
I would be like hang on a minute this
has gone horribly wrong for Magnus and
the queen is on F3 and there's a big
trap on the board so the whole point is
that the White Queen can't slide over to
the E2 Square because then the queen
would come down to H1 and that would be
the Checkmate that Simon was alluding to
yeah and the Queen on F3 just sits so
comfortably there and you can back it up
with a rook coming around okay Queen D1
clever move if the Queens come off white
will win because he's a pawn up but
black can obviously try to stop that now
Black's Queen has to move but whoa
okay what swapping Queens when you're
reporting down for Russia's Banking and
counter play on The Queen side but
surely this is not going to be
sufficient he's just going to get one
active Rook but white pawns later are
going to start marching and uh when they
do I really fear for black really
counter-intuitive trading the Queens
we're talking about Checkmate one second
ago
I mean this is this has maybe been a a a
a a mistake that we've seen a couple of
times there because uh in the last game
as well farouja had the chance to keep
the Queens on the board and play for
checkmate but he decided not to decide
to exchange the queens and again he's
exchanged the Queen's off so he can't
play the Checkmate anymore and I I think
this has made it from a free result game
where he could have won by keeping
Queens on to to a game where he's I
don't see how he can ever win this now
because uh he's a pawn down you know in
a middle game and it's just not enough
counter play about the queen I I would
assume plus this is treading into
magnus's strengths right he's fantastic
at the end game he's not only just a
pawn up he also has the better pieces
um farrugia I think once again if I'm
going to criticize him it's going to be
the queen traits
it just feels maybe like we've talked
about Battle of generations maybe a
little bit of uh kind of panic here just
maybe banking too much on calculation
rather than a general kind of feel uh
which Magnus kind of relies on sometimes
you just can't calculate you just have
to say to yourself it is that simple and
they're pulling down do not trade queens
and uh I mean my big advice against
Magnus Carlson is don't even go into an
equal end game against him but here
you're going into an end game of Pawn
down uh you're kind of giving him a
standing start you're giving him a
massive uh kind of handicap lead on you
here and okay all pawns on light squares
good kind of General chess wisdom there
uh for Magnus especially facing a dark
squared Bishop now where is this black
Rook going it's going to be slow it's
not going to be a quick knockout here
but Magnus if you can consolidate and
kind of Step his King forward start
activating the white Rooks which are
passive right now then feels inevitable
at this point on a slow and steady
he will improve his position
it's a nice time Advantage as well on
the clock I mean he's got a uh this
eight minutes versus
um and he raises two and a quarter
minutes and what Aldi raiser's got to
try to do here and he's trying is to get
his Pieces Just as active as his cat as
he can uh his dark Square Bishop has
some nice squares and a diagonal uh but
White's Bishop is very solid there
defending everything as well
um it's gonna be tough here though for
black I mean if the if you can look at a
pawn structure as well just imagine all
the Rooks coming off black could be in a
hopeless situation because the pawns are
on dark squares blacks pawns whites
pawns are on light squares what color
Bishop it is it's a dark Square Bishop
so that means all the endings without
Rooks will just be winning for white
very easily because white can Target
Black's pawns but black and his Bishop
can't Target White's Pawn so there's
that danger as well just to add
something else in
and should I say it no look at the bar
you guys do it Kaya yeah it feels like
it's well the bar says it's winning yeah
but where is The Knockout blue are there
some tactics in the uh Ivanka you're
looking very intently at the moment yeah
I was wondering whether you can get away
with uh The Rook check and then uh
pushing the pawn to F4
yeah it feels like this is in the air
either now or on the next move uh for
example if you do throw the pawn forward
uh if this Pawn is captured then maybe
you're idea now your Banker give a check
Force the black king into the corner and
then what next how to finish this one
off uh I wanted to say we just pinned
the bishop but there are some nasty
checks for the black Rook this is what
Magnus Carlson is calculating right now
can he go straight for the win the bar
says yes the evaluation bar
it's not obvious though I wanted to give
this pin but suddenly this check throws
a real spanner in the works no good
Square for the white king to go to if
you drop back to the light Square black
can actually unpin himself by dropping
back and due to the fact this white Rook
is undefended uh now protecting his
piece he's won the pawn back and
survives yeah maybe in that line you can
actually after F4 and the check for
example the check is a good check it
doesn't go for it but um I think you can
just swap Bishops and go King E3 and
this ending should be because you're
going to swap a pair of Rooks off a rook
F1
and um once you swap pair of Rooks off
the D6 Pawn I know you've given up a
pawn this way so it's risky but this
this ending with Rook F6 and E5 should
should be very unpleasant for black at
least so if I get you right Magnus he
wants the Rocks off
she wants uh I think anything off at
this point uh as long as he keeps his
Pawn Advantage uh the problem is if you
trade Rooks then as Simon pointed out
white has the better Bishop white has
the poor majority in the center if you
trade Bishops then it's just as we
showed in that variation it's actually
easier for white to start advancing the
poor majority uh so any peace trades
here pretty much favor White that's the
problem that's the first thing you think
about in endgame is kind of which
exchanges which trades suit me and here
for white it's everything pretty much
yeah so fruition just has to sit and uh
he's not allowing any trades yet that's
good yeah I like his last move because
now now The Rook ever checks the black
king the black king doesn't have to hide
in the corner it can come towards the
center maybe just because of that I was
thinking the best move might be to move
the bishop all the way to the edge of
the board and just keep that King locked
there on the G8 Square yeah I mean you
could even throw a check in first as
well maybe I mean um
and then move the Rook to G8 but they're
both Bishop H6 that's a great idea yeah
uh here uh to to stop the black king
from coming towards the middle but so
many tempting options here for Magnus
there are and this F4 move is always
there right uh just just playing for F4
and in this case you you could do the
same thing or sacrifice a form of f4
move your king fours and both your Rooks
are coming over to to uh cause a lot of
trouble so it doesn't yeah there's many
options here and Magnus taken his time
to think about it but this is this is
the best position Magnus has had so far
today uh there's no doubt about that and
uh Ali Razo he's paying for that pawn
sacrifice that he did and he's played so
well today but giving up the pawn like
that so quickly it was
pretty creative too creative maybe yeah
that's something that the top top
talents actually suffer from being too
creative oh you know they try to do
something special you know and they go
over the top and it actually backfires
and uh
um yeah it's you know Ali Razer is one
of those players that does do special
things but they they don't they can
sometimes not work yeah I'm Rook to C2
just a slow improving move and I I'm
inclined to agree Simon every time I see
these young players we talked about it
the other day with Abdi satoroff he's
really kind of it feels like he's kind
of uh just testing his boundaries seeing
how much he can get away with how
ambitious he can be without it
backfiring and sometimes it goes wrong
when you're young or inconsistent that's
natural but uh when it works it works
very very well exactly and that's why
these young players are rising towards
the top and I think in a few years time
fruge is still super young all of these
teenagers once they've kind of realized
what their strengths are what their
weaknesses are what they can get away
with how hard they can push then they'll
just become uh even better and I think
that's why Magnus we've talked about him
provoking his opponents pushing pushing
kind of getting away with kind of these
dodgy positions he knows the risk levels
that are acceptable and uh they're
getting to that level now they're
approaching him uh in terms of risk
assessment was minus like that as well
when he was a teenager in maybe early
20s where he would test his boundaries
basically definitely uh trying all sorts
of different openings uh that's kind of
Step One all sorts of different
positions Magnus was a grinder now he's
more aggressive because he's talking
aggressive yeah what a move this is oh
uh I mean he's played a move and again
look at the bar so we've all got it in
Kai and we're just ready
but he's sacrificing a pawn back here
and uh his last move was to try and get
his rook in on the C file but uh what is
the idea of if black simply takes that
pawn which he has to do right he can't
do anything else otherwise he he will
but I mean this is actually looking like
very close to Checkmate now even if
Black's not careful here where do you
even run if you run away from the center
then suddenly you get checked from
another angle and uh you get kicked you
get checked again and the black king is
uh forced to walk into no man's land and
I'm assuming there's a knockout blow
here I don't really see it immediately
but it feels like there is going to be a
Checkmate maybe something like this and
the white Rook can just uh come in maybe
just trap the black Bishop actually uh
in the center this looks deadly uh
Magnus is about to deliver this check
I'm assuming and uh maybe that means the
black king has to run towards the center
and where is the finisher here he
doesn't even give a check wow I was
going to say here you can go for some
nasty checkmates yeah but okay Magnus
just takes the slow approach positional
approach and he drops back eyeing up
this Pawn so he's giving the pawn back
its level material but uh he has
pinpointed a new weakness and the black
King's still in a bit of trouble
I'm Amazed by how Magnus is playing
because I expected this Pawn sacrifice
to be you know aiming at The Rook coming
in giving a check I mean that's just
irresistible to probably 99 of the
players but Magnus
he sees chess in a different way and
instead he drops the bishop back and
just goes for the week before Pawn yeah
now what would uh you'd be inclined to
do Magnus he's obviously looking at this
Pawn but he's also got tempting options
of the check going for checkmate again
he can activate this Rook which is
clearly the worst piece uh right now not
doing anything on B1 you could kind of
bring it to the open file try to kind of
do that pincer movement to Rooks uh
trying to catch the black king the
problem is is he didn't do it on the
last go he's done it now he's given it
okay well now what about this one you
know he's been inconsistent yeah the
bar's dropping and farusha has been
really clever here he's created an
evacuation Square an escape Square for
his King now a check will be met with
the King hiding out and it's actually
surprisingly safe on H7 uh this is the
big difference if Magnus had gone for it
quicker uh one move earlier this black
pawn would have been kind of back here
blocking The Escape of the black king
Sunday's game on yeah yeah and Magnus
leans forward is like he heard you there
David it's game on yeah I think he just
missed the black kings surprisingly safe
from H7
this bishop d2 move was very peculiar
it's very slow
um I mean had you checked uh had you
done the same thing you're pointing out
David you'd have forced Black's King to
go into the middle and then you could
have played Bishop D2 so you can have
the same position as this but Black's
King could be in the middle of the board
on a much more exposed Square so uh Addy
Razor's back in the game now uh his
King's quite safe and uh the H Pawn
could even cause white some problems now
I mean if you push it a couple more
squares it's uh going to be stabilized
on H2 so uh game on yeah and he will be
regretting his life choices Magnus
giving back the material and suddenly no
obvious moves you can give a check you
can try and catch that black king but
it's not going to get anywhere and if
you don't kind of have this material
advantage then suddenly the merge of
error uh what are you even playing with
the blacks Rooks are ready to get active
this could turn Magnus whoa retreating
his Rook he's just lost two moves for
free The Rook was here two moves ago a
sign of panic this is that's a really
sad move to play uh because you've
gambited a pawn then you've retreated
your Bishop you've checked your
opponent's king then you moved your Rook
back
I mean what what's going on here I mean
this is these are the kind of moves that
you just really never want to play
because you're admitting to yourself
I've played some bad moves uh and you
can see he's trying to hide his face
there and he's not happy and look at the
engine uh suggestions whoa okay you're
right Kaya there was only one move
actually there to call the balance for
black that was not easy it was the Black
coming down to A3 to Target White's B3
Pawn the weak ball on the queen side
instead he's gone back he's gone passive
with this Rook for Asia and now
Advantage white again but not obvious
anymore Magnus is in panic mode he found
his reverse gear and I don't know if
he's in the mood to go on the attack
anymore
what would be an attacking move now what
sign are we looking for that Magnus is
attacking to win this game well I would
expect the the white Rook on G1 to lift
up to the G5 square and attack the pawn
okay that's a Target
and black gives a pawn away uh just to
lure the white king distract the white
king and okay once again white is a pawn
up but is it enough this time
the black king is getting hit getting
checked but the white king not entirely
safe either yeah both of the black Rooks
are on quite a funny that they can be
hit by Bishop E3 uh but I I don't know
if there's any tactic that makes that
work
uh White's King is nicely situated in
the center of the board but what is the
move here is it to where where'd you put
your Rook
gives the check first of all
look at the bar sorry guy I'm stealing
yours
does drop after that last movement this
is the wrong way
had to keep contact with the white Rook
now the white king is perfectly safe and
now you can start using your C2 Rook
move it up the board move it maybe down
the board actually maybe down to C1 this
is a nice move as well I mean just
trying to force the Rooks off to to give
yourself a passport it looks like a nice
move computer doesn't like it but you
see this is a really nervy game I mean
the bar fluctuations I mean you want to
guess the accuracy of this game this is
uh certainly one of the lower lower
accuracy games we've had under 19 for
both players yeah under 90 about 85
and again the bar just going crazy again
oh Kaya
what a move giving away The Rook but
he's unpinned his bishop and the other
Rook Falls that was look at it the
engine said it just below the board for
a second there that was the only winning
move and Magnus found it and uh now it's
winning because look at the black king
is so far away from all the action which
is actually going to take place now one
second
oh the King's Running though a second
Pawn's about to drop Magnus can just
defend
he's winning can be two pawns up
it's dramatic for Ali reservous four
seconds on the clock in a losing
position
she pawns down simply White's B Pawn is
gonna be the winner here White's King is
going to run out the way clear uh the
path for the B Pawn to advance there's
no counter play on the other side of the
board the black king is active but it's
not threatening anything Magnus can just
continue advancing there we go
before he's going to get his King out
the way next move
surely
should be winning now but only a few
seconds each this is a bullet game
mistakes could still happen he's blocked
his own Pawn that's bizarre he's going
down
really strange stuff and now the black
king is kicking away this white Rook the
eporn will fall
he's lost one pawn and uh what about the
other Pawn as well I mean you know this
this is getting very close to being a
draw now we're gonna get a rook and pawn
ending white only has one Pawn left but
this is no but this one is lost for
black the black King's just too passive
here feel panic and suddenly the white
king is going to move out the way with
gain of tempo hitting the black rook and
the white d-pawn has a clear path
through it's going to run that's going
to be a new queen and farouza I think
he's resigned you can see Magnus shaking
his head there as well I think I think
they're both uh quite shocked with that
game but that is a heartbreak for veruga
Magnus Carlsen wins game three Ali Reza
farusha he is now
to take it to Armageddon to have any
chances of winning the Julia's very
generation cup it's looking great for
Magnus Carlsen after a dramatic game
back and forth the bar came alive what
happened here David the bar came alive
this was a crazy game Magnus was mostly
in control but he did give faruga some
big big chances to hold and even just
three or four moves before the end it
was technically a draw for Russia just
didn't have enough time on the clock to
find that path Magnus here went for it
he went for broke he went for gold here
with King to C6 hitting this Pawn the
blackrook correctly took here and now a
difficult only move to save the draw we
can forget varuja for not finding this
this is almost impossible instead of
Defending his Rook instead of reacting
to the attack on his Bishop as well he
had to forget everything and try to hit
the white Rook this would have broken
the white coordination and forced the
draw but this was difficult and it would
still have continued instead trading off
these Bishops allowed the white king to
move out the way and this was the winner
resigned was no way to prevent a queen
now from appearing on the board a great
game by Magnus Carlsen he takes the lead
in The Grand Final and with only one
game to go it's must win situation for
alireza fuja he has to win game four to
take it to Armageddon and that game is
coming up in a few minutes but first a
quick break
[Music]
one minute 10 seconds
surviving whoa he blundered his Queen
music
oh my God
quickly
oh my gosh
[Music]
it doesn't look like much but neither
would a Sicilian Defense to the
untrained eye this is a performance
enhancer you don't see it how about now
manage your air quality sharpen your
performance change the game with air
things
[Music]
thank you
Magnus Carlsen has taken the lead in The
Grand Final and this guy is actually a
former coach of Magnus Carl's knee is
also the reigning Norwegian chess
champion 41 years after he won the title
for the first time at 16 years old he
was able to beat Boris sposky and at the
same time as being one of the world's
best chess players he was also playing
for the national team in football or
soccer if you want today Simon Augustine
is the head coach for the chess players
at the Norwegian high school for Elite
Sports
we're about to enter the trainers
session you know the Norwegian college
level lead Sports and this is the chess
Department it kind of starts out the
already out here because I need some
space for my books they say that it's
kind of a Norwegian School
which is they focus on having fun to put
it simple at the moment there are 13
students here over three years
so it's the best scenario I would say
the best juniors in Norway perhaps even
this sofa is a little bit legendary
perhaps Magnus has been lying here and
he normally came into this office it's
just stretched out his hand just picked
anything I started reading just anywhere
I think this was fashionable in the
1970s the missions are high you want to
have an international masters Grand
Masters world champions We have a
handico had a couple of them actually
but at the moment most of my students
are 2 000 and writing and more and I
have a couple of GM candidates
tour
important to be fit but the kind of at
our level we practice kind of because
it's it's fun
that's the main reason we practice and
it's good to get go out a little bit
it's about the way of thinking I think
it's similar
if it's chess or football or basically
anything breaking barriers such things
it's easy to get to be distracted with a
little too much respect that if you kind
of broke in such barriers you get um
kind of this when you kind of Meet the
best in the world if you're not kind of
mentally prepared a bit worrispies when
I was 16. I kind of broken some barriers
as I played with the very best in the
world so I've kind of discovered early
that they weren't inhuman and I played
against Italy I played the Franco
barriers it was world champion how cool
is it to have Seaman a legend in
Norwegian chest as your teacher every
day I think it's very interesting and
very cool because he has a lot of
stories and obviously he's very good at
chess it's a wonderful experience and I
really appreciate the opportunity we
have here at Antigua
it is very special and very cool in
Norway to have an Elite Sports high
school with a group of chess players as
well Seaman he did Coach maybe one of
the greatest chess players of all time
Magnus Carlsen I'm excited now to hear
the lists top five goats in chess you
have all been asked to pick your top
fives I'll start with you ibekah who do
you think are the best chess players of
all time well I kind of wanted a
combination between historical figures
and current figures as well and I I was
also kind of very aware that I wanted
them to be very influential one and so
my well my one and number five is very
romantic she was the first women's world
champion also eight time women's world
champion and you know just an incredible
she competed amongst the top men as well
and the world and think about it it was
also in the 1920s and she sadly died in
1944 because of the world war and London
Blitz and then I was also had a talk
toss up between
historical Champions and it was like my
romantic side my scientific side and in
my end the end the scientific side one
and I was like okay what Mikhail bought
vinnick and that was to do with the fact
that he inspired several of the future
Generations he made chess a science and
then of course number three is Judith
poga one of my favorite female players
she just shattered the barriers she
broke Bobby Fisher's record and I could
just go on and on about her all day
incredible player I've eaten so many
world champions being in the world's top
ten so she was my number three number
two Gary Kasparov a man that I grew up
absolutely idolizing I loved his style
of play and for me number one oh drum
roll
the man playing in the tournament
Madness awesome
the goat for Ivanka is Magnus Carlsen
and Simon I'm excited to hear your list
now are you agreeing with yvanka on some
of these names I I am actually agreeing
with Ivanka quite a lot for probably the
first time ever no
but my number five is is Bobby Fischer I
think you have to have Bobby Fisher on
the list he uh really
um major so popular especially over in
America and uh it became cool in the 70s
when he won uh the world championship so
he was a legend in the game uh number
four for me was Paul morphy which is a
bit of a surprise but I personally love
the way he played chess he was called
the the pride and sorrow of the game he
he gave up and died far too early but
his games were magical and it was that
Romantic Era uh of Chess which he really
uh um played and uh really good games to
to look at and then Judith pogar number
three um I think you have to have her on
the list because she she was just so
strong and you know she uh she she her
and her sisters did so many great things
and inspired so many uh so much as well
and then Gary Kasparov he he was uh
number two yeah I'm following you here
um and you can't have a list without
Gary
um he was a really energetic player uh
brilliant player and number one well
yeah I mean we know we know the number
one is right I mean number one is the
one and only uh the legend of the game
Magneto the great Carlson and and I
think he has to be number one I don't
think there's any talk about that at all
32 years old you've still got time to do
more exactly so yeah he's still young so
yeah all right well David do you agree
or will you have someone else on top
let's start with your number five we'll
see number five this is maybe
controversial I've gone for Beth Harmon
he might not be real she might be a
fictional character but uh you talked
about influence your anchor and she has
brought chess to a wider audience the
Queen's Gambit everyone who came to
chess uh through watching that show I
think we have to thank her for that and
of course she beat the world champion
there so she she was pretty good um I
like it number four Judith Polgar
coolest one of the nicest people in
chess as well as the legend uh and a
monster on the board then Bobby Fischer
number three Gary Kasparov number two
and Magnus Carlson number one there we
have it there we go you all agree Gary
caspero number two Magnus Carlsen is the
one that our experts in the studio think
it's the greatest chess player of all
time the goat of Chess and right now he
is only one game away from winning his
third tournament on the Champions
Chester 2023 he will win the Julius rare
generation cup with a draw or a win in
this game four against Ali Reza of
Russia that means it is must win for the
French 20 year old he has the white
pieces and what does he need to do right
now Simon win yeah simple as that
and what do we think about his opening
wow yeah B3 not one B3 which uh has
become famous as a very ambitious move
these days but a spin on the Sicilian
this is relatively rare you've got to
say uh no open Sicilians nothing too
direct but it's really flexible and it's
forced Magnus Carlson to think this is I
think a decent winning attempt uh by for
Asia nice opening try here definitely
caught Magnus off guard and an opening
that makes me happy because I remember
when I was still an E4 player I was
struggling in the main lines they were
way too sharp for me so I was thinking
oh how can I switch things up again a
bit and I came up with this move as an
alternative and the idea is quite simple
you just want to develop your Bishop to
the long diagonal and
if you're allowed push up the poor
e-pawn one square further and then put
the bishop on D3 and
see I at one point in my life I was a
hacker oh yeah no no no I'm not like a
computer hacker
oh my goodness me
no no I I like to attack I like to throw
pieces
two you know tuned towards my opponents
so that means you're sort of hacking the
other yeah the opponent side of the
chessboard yes I like that yeah yeah no
not a computer anyone who knows me knows
that I was watching my streams knows
that I'm constantly having to call for
technical help yeah to help you turn the
computer on earlier literally
so yeah maybe like accidental hacking
another hacker here with us Simon uh
what are your thoughts on this uh
opening
um I think it's a great choice and I
think we can already see it it's a great
choice because Magnus is uh sunk into a
two-minute uh think here and uh there's
a lot of Venom in this move actually uh
one of our and compatriots Luke Shane
um who was called the strongest amateur
chess player in the world
um used to play this system quite a bit
and um there's there's a couple of ways
that black can play against it I've
looked to this as well because I think
like you Ivanka I didn't want to learn
the main lines because I was too lazy so
I wanted to learn a sideline and B3
seemed like a good move I mean you put
the bishop on B2 fantastic diagonal and
Black's got to make this decision now
um and what does black do there's a
number of ways you can play uh you can
develop one of your Knights you can even
challenge that pawn on e4 I think that's
probably the most uh
um direct move even with the pawn or
with the Knight as well Knight F6 and
play D5 D5 yeah and I I think this is
following we're talking about Bobby
Fischer and it's really hard that list
to put them in the right order I mean
you know it's going to have so much
discussion because Bobby Fischer could
be number number two as well I'm gonna
say number one uh on that list but I'm
sure Bobby Fischer had a game in this
precise line with the white pieces and
um I think this is considered to be
slightly better for white but a solid
Choice from black D5 David really solid
and uh the main line here as far as I
know uh okay these player the players
are uh kind of choosing the moves now
really quickly but uh after black takes
here after a Trader Pawns in the center
White Castles and the whole idea is to
quickly deliver a check and it's
actually a bit reminiscent of the
previous game where Magnus Carlson's
King got caught in the center of the
board he's taken with the Knight instead
but either way it's all about the bishop
landing on this diagonal and maybe white
blowing open the center while he hits
while he is ahead in development so uh
yep still in the days here but I really
like the opening Choice from furition I
think this gives him the best bet of
winning there's no guarantees a muscle
in situation even against uh well in any
scenario let alone against the best in
the world but he has caught Magnus
slightly off guard uh forced him to
think and he will get attacking chances
it's going to be imbalanced at least uh
no kind of boring symmetrical end games
this one is going to give white chances
later in the game
100 agree and white has very easy moves
to play as well I mean white can Castle
White can check the black king uh these
moves just natural and it's nice having
easy moves because you can save your
time uh for the middle game and uh you
can see that Magnus took on D7 with his
Knight that's not ideal because the
Knight on D7 is a very badly placed
piece actually as well but it does it's
the most solid choice because you keep
everything guarded here but can you
check and go Queenie too this is this is
the first thing that Springs to my mind
trying to stop Magnus from castling
because that'd be great right if we can
stop him from Castle that's actually the
main move another alternative is
actually to challenge the center
immediately by pushing the pawn forward
and I just got to tell you about the
stats the stats are significantly in
White's favor here 67 of the games have
finished in a white Victory wow 67. 67
yeah that's huge and that's not even
counting rules right nope wow so uh the
main sorry yeah white is doing well here
is because black can't Castle is tied
down uh to this bishop if you Castle it
simply falls off the board and uh simply
no way to compensate for this loss of a
piece so your king is stuck stranded in
the center again Magnus Carson makes it
work we've mentioned kind of treading
that fine line between uh Brilliance and
disaster uh he's kind of poised here if
it gets to the end game for that King to
be nice and active in the middle of the
board but well with Quinn's on this
looks really really dangerous and uh
what to do about this you need to
contort yourself here you don't really
want to step away from this pin you can
move your Bishop yes later but this Rook
is now kind of stuck in the corner
forever you're playing basically without
that Rook for the near future and uh
okay Magnus brings his Rook across wow
this is creative he's going to zigzag
his Rook off the board and block the
White Queen so white has two moves to do
something to hit before uh black is
already
yeah because uh and there's a quite a
nice idea here I mean if you ever try
Knight G5 maybe black can castle where
was that right no you can't still Castle
because it's a pin okay but Knight G5 is
not a very good move but I want to stop
that idea but I'm not in a good
situation to play something so
aggressive at the moment
um interesting idea Rook C8 though um
you know funny way to get the Rook
around because like white needs to do
something with these pieces still asleep
at home but yeah for usual with a lot of
choice let's leave him with this big
decision
he basically has those two Tempi as we
say in chess two moves before Magnus is
ready to bring his Rook around uh kind
of release the tension block everything
if he doesn't strike now for Russia then
Magnus will solve his opening problems
we do see the bars on his side so there
must be a way it's just about finding it
I wouldn't be surprised if Rouge
actually spends invests five or six
minutes here because it is that
important that states are that high in
this exact position
if
crazy position here yeah and it's not
only must win for alireza to be able to
win the tournament remember he needs to
win the tournament to be guaranteed a
spot in Toronto in the tour finals if he
doesn't win he still has to fight for
the points in the final regular event
that will be in three weeks I don't
think he is thinking about that right
now he just really wants to win this
game do you see chances for him to do
just that David definitely and I gotta
say I love this move from Far Asia he
didn't follow my wisdom he played this
move really quickly and I'm so impressed
uh this is not an obvious move it's not
a conventional move normally as we point
out the bishop wants to land on an even
longer diagonal than this uh usually the
home for this bishop is the B2 Square
where you're staring across the board
but this whole move uh the whole idea
here is really sophisticated he's
basically fighting against Black's plan
he knows what Magnus wants to do and
he's saying no you cannot do that if
Black's Rook lifts up the board now look
at this tension the bishop is blocked
but it can open up this diagonal by
sacrificing a knight just blowing open
the center the Knight now hits The Rook
stops the Black Brook from using this
Square also wants to land on the
Beautiful the dreaded F5 square and if
you take this Knight of course then your
position collapse Bishop takes E7 and
this will be deadly for the black king
what an idea really rare but uh really
nice concept nice idea been played two
times it's been played two times already
oh wow okay
I mean uh a great opening Choice
um by by Eddie razor here he's uh he's
found something that can cause Magnus
problems in the opening and you rarely
see this because Magnus is so well
prepared and uh he has some problems now
he he can't do his plan and moving The
Rook he can't Castle obviously if black
could Castle here black would be fine
but he can't he can't get his King safe
and white can still develop he can bring
his Knight out he can place a pawn in
the center trying to open it up and uh
there's a lot of danger here uh for for
black how does black try to get his King
safe here this is this is a big question
there's
it's not easy to see because you can't
move your queen you get checkmated on E7
I mean you can't really move your
Knights do you have to move your king
and but that looks ugly as well I mean a
very difficult position with black to
play here yeah it's kind of interesting
because
um the two games that I have in the
database both of them I don't know
whether it was by error or by plan but
they both went Rook to the C6 they
allowed white the trick
and how did those games end up one ended
in a draw the other one ended in white
winning
not just something stats for like this
just seems like a blunder doesn't it she
pointed out David that nice tactic of
Rook C6 Knight D4 beautiful beautiful
idea and uh Magnus needs to use his time
now because uh one and one bad move you
just you just lose this position so easy
it's that critical right now yeah ready
King Stuck In The Middle on the open
file is scary
stuff so we've seen it a couple of times
this tournament uh games we would call
Miniatures Knockouts in under 20 moves
and this has the potential for that
again and I think that's why we see
Magnus carlsen's body language uh we're
used to seeing him really relaxed but I
think he's a bit kind of uh just bemused
here he's thinking how with very natural
moves am I into this much trouble
potentially as black and in the end he
decides on the Move A6 minimizing his
time disadvantage I was going to say as
well he was three and a half minutes
down on the clock nearly four minutes
down there and uh okay he decided A6
here
the idea I guess is to advance pawns on
the queen side to eventually Target and
kick away White's Bishop but it looks so
slow he's just banking on the fact that
maybe there's no immediate way for white
to uh kind of continue this attack to
build the momentum yeah what moves to
come to mind here well Knight D4 again
is quite interesting trying to get the
Knight to F5 uh so couple of moves I
mean that that would be one idea putting
a Pawn on D4 I'm just trying to find
because again it this this position is
quite is really critical timing wise
because if black is able to uh calm the
position down play these Pawn pushes and
castle
he won't be in any trouble at all so as
white here you you've gotta you've got
to think of ways to do things quickly uh
to maintain your advantage you can't
play you know you can't play Slowly here
so move like Knight D4 is quite logical
but it it's probably very easy to stop
that idea
um of moving the night swear five just
played G6 I guess is very simple
stopping that one idea so you can maybe
put a Pawn on that square or just
develop another piece as long as you've
got an idea behind it but
um maybe moving to porn is is a critical
option My Vibe is uh move the pawn
forward but uh the problem is is that
once the night that sorry once the Rick
comes to the C6 Square then uh you don't
have your knight D4 oh yeah it's
actually really clever really
sophisticated the by Magnus this is a
deep move uh his last move Pawn to A6
he's basically waiting slightly
improving his position but he's waiting
for elevator to play the move he wants
to play uh like Ivanka says because
actually you blocked that Square from
your own Knight and it's like a waiting
game it's saying okay I know you want to
play this move but that will help me as
black and now the Rook will come across
and if you do take a pawn for example as
soon as the black Rook lands on this
Square blocking this tension along the
eval breaking the pin uh suddenly black
will be ready in the next move or two to
Castle and uh most likely win the pawn
back as well so
okay first is going for something else
he's played Pawn to C4 this is a trap of
course you cannot now push this Pawn
forward because of this tactic we've
been mentioning Knight takes pawn and uh
the Knight is poisoned because suddenly
the bishop behind it would fall uh so
okay he's asking different questions and
note how he's left this D4 Square empty
for his Knight to land on both players
playing really really well right now um
this is really high level chess and
Magnus he's got to continue finding
these uh deep Concepts just to survive
the center is about to explode and this
is kind of instructive from farrugia
always open the center if your
opponent's king is weak especially if
it's stranded uncastled uh and
especially if you're headed in peace
development
that's what he's going for right now so
do you think this will be another game
where Magnus does not Castle as king
it's looking that way right now it's
looking unlikely that the black king can
ever move without dropping the bishop it
has to stay in the center just to
protect
he would love to somehow find some
Maneuvers to block the e-file and get
that black king to safety but
normally I remember one of my first
coaches was saying always castle by move
12 otherwise you'll get checkmated and
it's move 11. although it doesn't feel
as if you're playing too safe right now
if you're Magnus Carlson
thinking for two minutes on this move
Magnus Carlsen what will he do
I don't see a sensible move here or at
least a natural kind of productive move
I am also lost as well because I just
don't see anything natural and we do see
Magnus move his Knight to the fa Square
getting ready to put it on E6 so okay
maybe Magnus is just going to curl up
into a little ball you know then
put the Knight onto G6
and then castles yeah I mean I think
both esix and and G6 are good squares of
the night just get castled then
um two moves and it'd be out of danger
right if you can move the Knight and
Castle but that gives white two moves to
stop that well we are hoping for an
Armageddon to decide this Grand Final
and uh it's not looking impossible right
now
no definitely on the cards if uh farusha
is energetic enough here uh Knight on f8
we need more rhymes for that one but uh
yeah two moves as you said how can
alireza continue the action he's got two
moves I wanted to bring my knight out
here as black but I don't see how to
continue after the Black Knight blocks
and it's only one move and Magnus is on
paper saying this uh in interviews he uh
Ivanka you know this one better than me
I think but he said if you're three
moves away from castling you're in big
big trouble uh if you're two moves away
you can survive if you're one move away
you should be okay and here he's just
two moves away so he's on the brink
balancing on the edge of being all right
yeah
yeah I know it's a really shaky position
I mean I was thinking after this night
Retreat that white will simply go okay
you go backwards I go forwards and move
with the night ah look that way I wasn't
thinking that I was thinking Knight to
D4 okay Knight to D4 Ivanka it's the top
computer if we see the engine
suggestions uh below the screen there
nice one jumping in this time to uh to
F5 and we talked earlier about how you
have to uh stop that you have to stop
the night landing on the beautiful F5
square but suddenly this would backfire
not sure exactly why but maybe it's just
because this pin is unbreakable now and
this Black Knight is sitting silly on
the f8 square
not in a fight though might be a
Checkmate this time oh looking at ideas
from Queen E5 and oh okay computer hates
it but just uh some ideas of taking this
Knight which is pinned maybe you can
just go nicely free yeah that's what I
thought introduce everyone to the party
yeah look at all the white attacking
pieces one two three four five that's
basically fighting with the lone king
and a couple of pieces around it but
all the fun for white right now and if
he finds this move computer says it's
less than a plus one advantage but it's
the type of advantage that could grow
and just uh go through the roof if uh
Magnus doesn't defend well Knight to D4
would be strong is it also a move that
for a human eye will it will look much
stronger than for a computer yeah
normally it might not be obvious but
here it's been a recurring theme over
the last three or four moves already so
it's already high on ferris's radar
fighting to win this game only reservous
and take it to Armageddon against Magnus
Carlsen I have to say Magnus looks chill
he knows he has a second life both uh in
this match and in the Grand Final if he
does lose it in Armageddon then there
will be a grand final reset with best
out of two rapid games and potentially
Armageddon to decide it
that would have been fun oh my God or
maybe it still will be fun but uh
farusha needs to be decisive here okay
he jumps in with the Knight to a
different square but this was also on
the computer's list of candidate moves
and it looked promising and okay this
time we see Black's replies and
only two moves to keep the damage under
plus one here for white which would uh
kind of signal a large Edge there
and I'm not sure they're totally obvious
Simon the computer is saying either
block the center with Black's d-pawn
just close it down or use the black Rook
to defend the black Bishop on the
seventh rank they're both very passive I
mean it might be worth just showing why
Knight E6 doesn't work now because black
really wants the castle so you'd love to
play Knight E6 right I mean that that is
a move uh where black is now ready to
Castle if he gets one more move he's
fine maybe he's even better in this
position but it's White's move and white
can now strike uh with Knight takes F7 I
mean there might be a knight D4 here
just
or maybe
holding on but I don't believe it so at
the very least you take this queen and
uh this end game I guess your report up
yeah at the very end here but just to
show the points I'm in 197 destabilizing
the protection of the Knight on E6 and
boom Queen takes E6 here Killer attack
you've won a pawn and we'll win the game
so yeah this is the idea really nice
move also if the Knight goes to G6 to
protect its Bishop this was the other
direction we were talking about then the
Knight is just eliminated on that square
and the game continues with Black's King
in the middle
still stranded uh just to show the
computer's top moves here
very sophisticated Rook C7 defending the
bishop uh before it gets directly hit
again that's not obvious at all he's
played Knight G6 Magnus Carson
and
computer hates it Knight takes G6 looks
uh kind of automatic here maybe you
don't even need to rush maybe you just
blow up in the center uh wow and again
computer thank you stockfish you're
helping us out here massively Pawn to D4
just explode the position and this is
winning for white apparently over plus
two Advantage wow decisive wow and you
did say that is uh kind of the way
alireza likes to play as well exploding
open the center yeah exactly just to
show the idea if Pawn takes porn now we
trade the knights off first and once
again the bishop is open uh three
attackers on the Square only two
Defenders
all right great chance of getting an
Armageddon I know exciting times you
guys
can Ali reservosa win this game to take
you to the armaged
again the bar is liking the situation
for alireza Magnus Carlsen in trouble
here
but he has been quite resourceful today
minus Carlsen fighting out of some
difficult situations he's been very
resourceful uh with a bit of a helping
hand from alireza but Pawn to D4 here
simply must happen I was talking about
trading Knights first but actually this
might be some counter play against the
white King on the H violin oh he doesn't
play the pawn to D4 he plays the second
best move but now Magnus is still alive
Punta D4 might just have been a knockout
it's very good yeah I mean it you know
opening the center open the position
where your opponent's king is trapped
there it's kind of uh quite logical this
move also does seem very logical right
you develop your last piece you put some
pressure on black center and uh White
still has the advantage no doubt about
that but this may give black a chance to
consolidate things somehow uh possibly
pushing the pawn or uh can he ever get
castled he still can't get castled here
right I mean uh I think it makes sense
to play that D4 move right now first of
all it has natural right you want to
correct your Pawn structure also you
want to eliminate the possibility of
trades in the middle and also
alireza is such an active player I'm
sure that and the next move he will also
be thinking about just exploding
everything he's played it yeah it is on
the board Magnus accurate when he needs
to be
yeah sometimes you know what your
opponent wants to play Magnus was aware
maybe that D4 is an idea for white so
he's blocked it locked it down and
prevented D4 uh by playing it himself
simply and yeah I'm surprised by Furious
move I mean it was natural but uh now
the follow-up is less natural putting
the Knight on the edge of the board
there are some threats uh due to the
fact that the black Bishop is kind of in
a pin right now uh there might be
threats to capture on the C5 Square
white tonight and Bishop what else are
they doing on the edge of the board
other than attacking that black Pawn on
C5 but yeah this is the thing after the
black king moves suddenly you're stuck
with two bad pieces and the stakes are
higher now if you don't strike in the
next few moves you're just kind of
regretting those two pieces
I'm really surprised gotta say not just
because we saw the evaluation uh earlier
and we saw that white did have a winning
move uh helping hand which the players
don't have of course but just because it
looks unnatural putting the Knight on A4
like this
yeah yeah but I think that alireza
simply forgot that the black king can
move to a fade because for so long it
hasn't been a great move
and now suddenly it is
is just one of those things and still
the position I feel is very murky it's
still a lot of danger for both sides
David kind of mentioning that alirez's
pieces on the A-line
they ain't good but on the other hand
Magnus still has problems with his King
and with the Rook on h8 anything can
happen and as the clocks tick down
well it's gonna get even more exciting
yeah
suddenly I would think I would take
black
I just feel that white has no obvious
moves here and unless yeah unless you
find something then things are going to
change coming to F3 okay he's hitting a
Pawn on the diagonal uh with that White
Queen the pawn of B7 hanging but it
feels like black should be able to deal
with this in several different ways you
can defend that pawn with the queen
slightly tempting to push that one uh if
Magnus is feeling ambitious aggressive
Ferris is trying to make things work
with tactics
well it feels like we're reaching like
we've been building up to this point and
okay he hits the knight in the center
now if there's a trade of knights if
white tonight goes and captures a black
knight then the H file will open the
white king not entirely safe oh
yeah I agree with this uh twitch comment
the computer hates everything nowadays
but especially you know especially in
these complicated positions when there's
so many tempting moves on every turn
accuracy is hard to maintain yeah yeah
especially when the nerves are high yeah
I'm uh talking about maintain I think
that alireza should be maintaining that
night there on E5 it drop it back to the
D3 square and as David says do not trade
off Knights that's exactly what
Blackwood wants because the night The
Rook there on h8 would suddenly get a
lease of life
this is on the board he has to attack he
has to win this game yeah and there is a
far Asia can you see that from the
decision he sees he's constantly making
now that he has to win this game yeah
he's been taking big risks he's chosen a
great opening but he hasn't found that
killer blow I think that's uh something
we saw for example yesterday in the
clash between ferrugia and Dennis
lazovic that amazing
that amazing final game there where
Dennis had it pretty much in the bag but
finishing off these top players in the
world that's another level that's the
hardest thing to do and okay Magnus
solidifies his Queen side
connects all his pawns there
what next fruition needs to open
something
needs to do it quickly
black king still not castles so the
black Rook on h8 is still jailed uh
still kind of unable to enter the action
okay I said I'll take black
who's uh who's agreeing with me who's
disagreeing here I want to know
because it is a crazy position still
just for fun I'm going to choose white
precisely because of this move you know
I was thinking you have to make sounds
of those pieces on the edge of the board
and the computer hates this but on a
practical level I think this is good
white now has a very simple plan of just
putting those works on the open b line
and the White Knight can spring forward
Anders and and and I forgot the most
important thing there is a pawn Under
Fire there on A6 oh trust you to spot
that pawn
yeah why not grab it why not get greedy
and uh again we see stockfish the
computer suggesting King to G8 that's
not obvious the black king is on a
slightly open diagonal but running
towards the corner when it looks like
your house is on fire on the other side
of the board slightly counter-intuitive
first he trades a set of pieces not
allowing white to grab any pawns and
then he runs
and uh okay white is playing with an
extra piece that black rook and h8 we've
been talking about it a bit but still
stuck yeah time for alireza to
consolidate the cf4 pawn and then just
work on targeting the B6 pawn and uh no
alireza playing very actively with the
queen making every Pawn Grabber on the
planet very happy
shout out to yesterday one who will be
very happy with this move uh going after
these two black pawns now one of them's
gonna drop
and uh okay how to best defend this for
black Magnus the problem for him is
defending is so much harder than
attacking especially now the clocks are
ticking down
and yeah it's not going to be hot uh not
gonna be easy sorry to survive these
next few moves okay still tightrope as
said there in the future chat
this is balancing on a knife edge
especially for Magnus sticks are high
yeah
two minutes and 20 seconds left four
minus Crossing only three seconds
increment but he still looks so chill
Magnus Carlsen he has been in this
situation so many times
with a drawer or a win he's gonna win
the Julius bear generation cup it's
getting so close for him
experience is that gonna be the key what
do we think it's the battle of the
generations yeah experience of time
scrambles defending bad positions
I don't know but this generation they're
so experienced like I saw an interview
with a with young Christian of Judah and
he was like I played 20 000 games online
oh yeah
and I remember when Ali Reza was playing
the candidates do you remember he had an
all-night session playing bullet yes and
you know it was a constant chess
so we have seen the stats actually uh
before right these two have played so
many Blitz and bowler games against each
other I think on leeches is where we've
seen that maybe yeah and uh I mean
there's other sites of course but guess
how many games farrugia has played on
chess.com alone
flits bullet for time controls
I've just pulled out the stats how many
David 32 457.
wow it's a lot of time spent playing
chess yeah yeah
he's only played the chess for a little
over 10 years remember he revealed that
yesterday incredible how he's become one
of the best players in the world in only
uh a little over 10 years
Simon how many games do you think you've
played in your lifetime loads I don't I
don't want to look it's it'll be there
used to be this um and then maybe they
still have it on one of the big chess
sites where you can actually see what
percentage of the year you're playing
chess uh and I think it also gives you a
percentage of your life so it's like you
have been playing chess for like five
percent this year and I did this one
time and it was like I don't know what
the number was but it was far too high
and I was like oh my god I've got to get
out and get some fresh air this is
terrible it's such a scary uh stat
saying you've literally spent 10 10 of
your life sitting a computer playing
chess and I was like but then again what
would be a better thing to spend your
time on just like going for a walk
occasionally or you know just saying
yeah I mean you can play a bit of Chess
but you've got to have a breakdown again
you know so I wonder what the highest
percentage in anyone who plays chess is
probably like 40 or something I bet
there's someone there who just plays
chess you know moving that Mouse yeah
all day and all night until they sleep
they must be so yeah it's scary I
remember you got my page up
yeah
Magnus is thinking how to compensate
let's do a guess Kaya Ivanka games with
Simon played on chess.com Alone by the
way I have played for quite a long time
I just want to put that out there so for
Russia had a somewhere above 30 000.
yeah I'll go uh 60
000.
slightly on the high side but your
Banker
I would scare the same 30 000. okay 25
000. 300. I thought it was a lot worse
than that that's okay but I play like
they're like two hour games like
classical chips so seven games each
seven hours each per game so what about
David now I've got a game back now okay
anyways David you've got to tell us what
you've got now that's only fair come on
remember David also usually plays for
what five six seven hours when he plays
over the board he does conservatively
only eleven thousand uh
[Laughter]
somewhere else yes anyway back to the
game and uh we talked about Pawn
grabbing for Asia has grabbed a pawn
everything else looks still uh hasn't
changed too much but it's just the clock
times they have been ticking down and uh
also the Black Knight landing on F4
that's a very good news for Magnus
Carlson uh at least for the first time
in this game here's some active place
and counter play the white king no
Defenders around it as well so he needs
to somehow generate activity on that
flank I'm looking at the black rook in
the corner on h8 there we go comes to
life hits the White Queen across the
fifth rank that is blocked however and
Magnus is quickly replied
he's trying to force a rook trade at
least this would help him in terms of
one passive piece being traded off for
White's very active rook in the center
but still a pawn down it's been very
interesting this game all the way
through I mean it was uh Ali razor who
was attacking but now Magnus has kind of
turned that around it maybe sacrificed
the pawn but he's got this initiative
you look at White's King white doesn't
have any pieces around the king but the
Black Knights are getting nearer to the
white king So Ali Razer he's just got to
try to defend any attack Checkmate is
threatened on the board now that Queen
so the White Queen defends it they're
both short of time if he can just stop
uh the attack here then Ali razor should
should be doing very well here yeah can
he stop the attack though well how is
that going to continue the attack
because uh the queen and the Knights are
kind of all working together from a long
distance they're only pointing at the G2
Square it has been covered by the queen
next move by alireza will be to
introduce the Rook to the E7 Square
he's coming in he needs to do something
Magnus he needs to somehow zigzag his
Rook over to the G file go for the G2
Pawn well he needs to do something and
he needs to do it quickly he could also
maybe try and threaten the White Queen
but look at the clock times
or he has played Queen to C6 and okay
he's cut out the idea of Bishop landing
on the D6 Square I think you might be
right Ivanka the white Rook needs to
activate maybe into the position uh at
some point you need to get these two
pieces working it's all about the attack
on this Square the G2 if black can ever
break through all that square he will
deliver Checkmate but why this is still
a pawn up and uh Rooks are about to be
traded
Agnes is he guiding this to safety five
seconds he made that last move with just
two seconds left brings the ship here
he's got eight seconds I didn't realize
how short a time he is so this is
getting very very critical now I mean uh
it still seems like white should be
holding this but can Magnus now move his
Queen into the position he can't because
the Knight is attacking us
he's blundered he's just blundered the
the Knight aren't we heading to
Armageddon I think we are one second for
Magnus he moved there with less than one
second on his clock he's forgotten about
this check this is the key the killer
picking up another Pawn with Jack only
then going for the Black Knight and
white will be two pawns up in this queen
end game he is winning now for Russia
it's all about technique if he's calm if
he can control his nerves he's winning
but he's two pawns up on both sides of
the board he has a poor majority
it should just be a matter of time
Magnus needs a miracle incredible come
back
two pawns up and that should be enough
right I mean but it is very short time
and uh that means the valley razor does
win this game we're gonna get Armageddon
this move this is lovely absolute killer
that Pawn's gonna become a queen you can
see it Magnus has got his head in his
hands there I think he's gonna have to
resign very shortly and uh we're gonna
get more chess is this one we bring this
up Simon yeah yes yeah I think it's
about time and look at that the queen
centralizes itself and now the white
porn can advance the white king is safe
as houses there on H2 it is just gonna
be a master class in Queen and pawn
endings from alireza farouza even
playing with seven seconds on the clock
yeah he's doing the right thing he can
take his sweet time about it Magnus has
no easy moves meanwhile white just needs
to prevent any checks against his King
while combining it with promoting his
Pawn First we'll give a check maybe
he'll even take a pawn uh on D4 in the
next few moves but okay he's still
making it hard Magnus here how does
white prevent any checks along this
diagonal how does white activate his
Queen to help his Pawn promote
okay he hasn't made much progress what's
happening what's happening now this is
your passive crazy ridiculous I mean
these Queen and porn and he's
notoriously hard but uh I think he's
just he's just gone too passive no you
can take the pawn what is he doing the
nerves are kicking in for alireza here
he could have gone for it he could have
tried to promote his Pawn quickly he's
taken a time out and suddenly he's
walking forward with his King but this
is not in the safe Direction
oh it still looks borderline winning but
there is a way for Magnus customers draw
how is he going to do it he can give a
check he can go back with the black
queen White Queen has paralyzed here she
cannot support her pawn and defend her
King at the same time second time we've
seen this position and there is a has to
play for the win he has to come forwards
here but does Magnus have a Perpetual
check he just needs to keep checking the
king now is there any way that King can
escape the black queen seems to be far
too active here and the white king is
just running around look at this Magnus
not sure what to do he's only got nine
seconds it's so tense these endings
forget about the evaluation bar they're
so hard to work out one second
and he does what but what about can you
Queen here what's happening here he's
threatening to skewer the white white
king and queen he wants to go Queen H2
check
under solution it's defending the White
Queen that is genius now the white
King's gonna run that is a ridiculous
move absolutely ridiculous and why check
there why did he check there what you
check on the E3 he could have checked on
E3 and taken on D3 doesn't understand it
she's making those moves oh but he could
have just taken okay well now suddenly
the Knight has disappeared but oh my
goodness me is another reason winning
again he is winning again hold your
breath because this could still go
either way Magnus is going to give a
bunch of checks if he can okay first he
goes to the corner the problem is that
King's just caught in no man's land it's
going to get checked the pawns are gonna
run yeah I mean Magnus is so annoyed
with himself and I I just don't
understand I mean he's had no time is
the clock the clock is what has uh just
completely destroyed him in this game
yeah the pawn is running and uh the
White Queen beautifully centralized
she's gonna help block any incoming
checks
it's gonna still be 100 move game this
is still going to be a grind it's going
to take an age but for Asia should be
winning in Practical terms you can never
defend these no I mean well one Pawn is
hard enough but with two pawns uh it's
impossible but we have said that before
uh today we even got the the you've got
to resign t-shirt out but uh it's uh you
know he had a chance to save it is is
ridiculous and uh
I mean this is this is a the way you win
this you always have some kind of uh
block with the queen to stop the checks
and a cross check and uh that that's
what White's gonna probably do at some
point
um I'm expecting that now but no he
steps the king forward to age six no
more checks for the black queen
really clever no tracks there the white
a pawn is actually irrelevant that would
just be a distraction it's all about the
white d-pawn running you can push that
pull now
um
ah or now maybe sooner or later you've
got to start pushing your pawns the
black King's running over farouza feel
his play feels nervy and understandably
with such high stakes but finally he
goes for it the pawn is running 10 11
seconds there for fuchsia should be
enough now just keep pushing it's a
simple plan
yeah I mean you've always got to be
you've always got to be careful he's
checked so you push the pawn and now the
black queen can come in and check okay
please grab one Pawn but uh that pawn is
two squares from queening it looks to be
far too strong here
Black's King you actually want it it's
counterintuitive if you want it as far
away as possible because now you're
going to get caught in the crossfire
with some cross checks as they say this
uh check might be blocked by the White
Queen there we go and the black king
wants to be further away
God what's happening oh my god oh these
are so hard
cable base and table saying that the
only way to draw was to put the King on
the D5 square but now it is a win for
white because of the Cross checks again
you can't check because the check on F7
the Queens come off and the evaluation
bar these are the hardest endings
because computers can work them out so
quickly but for humans it's nearly
impossible to work out the right place
for the queen
especially with no time on the clock I
think it's as you said they were just
the practicality of defending this is is
really hard but it's a draw again now
now the backing is going around oh he's
gone the wrong way he could have come
nearer to the pawn there you just go
around you need to go back via B5 and
then C6 towards the white Pawn but he's
doing what he should do in terms of
textbook chess we study uh kind of these
Queen and Pauline games in books and
they always say bring the king as far
away as possible that was the exception
he needed to actually go closer to the
pawn and the reason that King's in the
corner now is because he won't get
checked too many times also stalemate
ideas watch out for those uh for example
black could play Queen to be through
there uh trying to play for stalemates
and uh yeah King D5 would have been the
only move right so yeah that was a very
nice trick there
um is it still nervy for future very
nervy very nervy
definitely tell that in his play here
and uh he's just got to find a safe
place for his King and if he can do that
he can push the pawn
um but
I mean I I wouldn't even know this was
winning now without the the bar because
the black king has found itself in quite
a safe place well the last porn move was
on move 81.
but bear this in mind because as the
players tick down and they get nervous
then uh inaccuracies will happen
and maybe Magnus can claim a 50 move
rule okay and the pawn is ready to push
next move it's guaranteed now there's no
more checks he needed to hold out until
move 131 without allowing the pawn to
step forward but then the counter resets
the 50 move rule is obliterated there uh
we start again and Magnus needs to
survive not allow another queen to
appear on the board but oh there were no
tracks there he's pinning the pawn he's
living right on the edge yeah the the
black queen is just too passive the way
you want to try win these positions is
keep your queen in the middle because if
the queen in the middle you control more
squares and White's Queen is just
controlling so many more squares than
the black one and Uh I that D Pawn is so
close to queening now I keep thinking
Magnus is going to resign though I did
about 50 moves ago and he keeps finding
some resource to to play on here pinning
the pawn now and white just guarding
against that yeah and the uh beautiful
thing here for ferruges you can just go
round and round around eventually you
find the right configuration and you
make a new Queen and this is clever if
any checks appeared on the H file White
Queen would have blocked I'll note how
the black king is actually on a
vulnerable diagonal as well you cannot
now for example check on the H file
because of Queen H7 check and the Queens
would come off white would win so he's
trying to defend from afar but now with
some zigzags you can inch closer with
the White Queen check check and
eventually you cover the promotion
square of your Pawn this should be game
over now yeah a couple of checks here
and I I think it's gonna be
Armageddon time it's going to be
Armageddon yeah we're gonna get it so I
I think Mangus is going to be so annoyed
with this game uh because he had many
chances
quite nervy quite a nervy game this one
you can see that the tension is very
high I mean it's been a roller coaster
of uh uh sort of up and downs here and
uh they both had chances but in the end
defending was just a bit too hard he's
still got to win it what movie on now
440 yeah yeah it's like 8036 yeah it's
four in the morning and uh yeah I mean
it must be a hundred and something now
121. yeah 21 wow
this might be the last few moves though
because I think if the white king just
uh okay I was gonna say slides across
one square but uh he's going to find
safety soon and the white Pawn should
promote this might be the Clincher you
cannot give any checks because remember
the block and the hit on the black king
okay now the Queen's behind the pawn
pawn is pinned you can't promote but the
white King's gonna run to safety
still a bit nervy it seems with the
white yeah but it's so hard to know
where do you put your king to escape the
checks he could have put it in the
corner on h8
yeah I think you're right Ivanka that
might just have been winning and Magnus
Carlson I've seen it before there was a
famous game against gregorians yeah this
is it yeah there's nothing there's
nothing to be done here yeah so some
stalemates I was gonna say he saved some
stalemates before but the black king is
not trapped in the corner he's trying to
check don't take the queen it's poisoned
that would be stalemate and a draw I
promise you don't have to take the queen
and Magnus he's gonna resign two queens
are better than one it's over and this
means everyone we will see Armageddon to
decide this match in the Grand Final in
the Jewelers red generation cup an
amazing comeback by alireza farusha to
win game four in a must win situation
how impressed Simon are you with the 20
year old very impressive and he just
kept on going and going there and uh you
know Magda saws he has some chances but
he just kept the pressure up and that
was key in that match and uh yeah it's
going to be a really exciting Armageddon
game now really exciting and it was a
long drawn out end game as well that Ali
Reza won so Ella Ellie Reza will be
feeling elated for Magnus it's just an
exercise in frustration he knows that he
shouldn't have gotten to this point but
we are going to be treated to an
Armageddon and I'm dying to know who has
picked the black pieces yeah we will be
excited to see the beds but first David
what a game take us through the
highlights here what a game a roller
coaster full of ups and downs there but
congratulations to alireza farrugia for
fighting back and taking it a real
clutch Victory it was this one moment
where he actually confused Magnus
Carlson and managed to confirm that
winning Queen and Pauline game and it
was here after Magnus played the really
sneaky move Queen to E2 if ferrugia here
had promoted to a queen the idea was to
skewer the white king to the White Queen
afterwards and uh when the working
sidesteps we would have seen a drawn end
game instead farouza played the really
ingenious move knight uh promotion Here
pawn to C8 under promoting to a knight
defending the queen and as we saw a bit
later on the Knight did eventually drop
but white was able to win with the extra
deep on crazy game but for Russia took
it
incredible stuff and that means the
Grand Final uh could be now decided with
an Armageddon game winning one game each
Magnus crawls of Russia they tied their
match a normal get on it's coming up in
a few minutes you guys here first is a
break
[Music]
look at the clock I don't think alireza
has enough time to convert this
Advantage is oh my goodness this guy is
unreal peruz is relaxed say Magnus needs
to win Chad will he do it Chad is Magnus
gonna win or not and this position looks
really good for black as he steals a
pawn in the center This Is The Moment of
Truth here okay well magnet oh he's
making to the loose oh he's made it I
can't even say no it's done Thomas
he doesn't even celebrate Vegas Carlson
still has that edge right that that made
him the goat and got him to be the best
player in the world the highest rated
player in history uh-oh but now things
have turned around and for Rouge has got
attacked Magnus is like unbelievable
there oh my goodness Bishop takes H3
with mate on H2O
Magnus has already won a match today
he's looking fresh feeling fresh in his
home environment the lead on the clock
for Magnus I think that might even be
the worst part is not only are there two
past pawns supported by Bishop and then
the kicking whoa he resigns seconds
early and Perugia leans back and Magnus
is celebrating that's it Magnus moves on
to the Grand Final and he's dancing into
a matchup against akara Nakamura
it was super exciting when Magnus and
alireza played the bullet Chess
Championship and some more excitement is
coming up with Armageddon between these
two incredible chess players another
incredible chess player is
eight-year-old Madonna we have been
getting to know her during this
generation cup and here is the story of
an incredible young girl who is very
good at chess
we're here for a special event but
Hannah is going to give a clock symbol
against six of Harrow chess club finest
I'm gonna try to win all the games
[Music]
when one of my dad's friends was
throwing away some things
I started asking about some pieces and
then I said that I wanted to take them
away but then my my dad said we needed
them and then he taught me how to play I
like that I could win games and more
trophies and also I could go to more
countries and make more friends
when I first met her uh at this blitz
tournament yeah she won this ending
obviously this should be drawn but um
she won this and I thought Heavens
that's something I'd hoped to do in a
Blitz game just by playing and playing
I'm just impressed by this
and I thought this is really fantastic
that this young girl can can play this
well
I don't know what stage it actually
becomes winning it's already very very
unpleasant at this point
these two I got on my first
International Tournament in Serbia
there's another three somewhere here
which I got in Greece but I'm not sure
where they are because there's so many
of them I quite liked this one because
straight after I got it I started trying
to like break it off because
this far kind of breaks off it
her thing is positional grinding and she
is pretty scary at that Knight F6 good
um she's very good at Rook endings
actually really in the same ballpark as
as you know proper international players
and Checkmate well done you spotted the
queen sacrifice immediately did it did
it just come to your mind yeah I'm
impressed you're getting them all I
thought that would be tough but no
my dad doesn't really want to play
against me now I think he doesn't want
to get beaten we haven't played for a
long time so I think I would beat him
though
my goal is to become the youngest I'm GM
in the world or if not then the youngest
GM in UK after that I want to play in
the world championships and get world
champion I think it will be hard but I
still think I can do it it's a perfectly
reasonable ambition she understands
she's the best in her age in the world
in the world at the moment so why
shouldn't she carry on being I hope she
comes up to a very strong player indeed
the final score was Butana Five Points
Harrow chess club one point
[Applause]
two twin sisters whenever I try to teach
them they just run away like I started
when I was five and a half and I keep
shouting at them saying you you don't
even play chess yet
looking at this young girl I guess there
is no doubt the future is bright for a
chance you won't go no I mean it's
really bright especially I'm especially
excited for English chess as well
because I'm also hoping that her success
can also kick start a new generation of
young girls coming in from England and
uh just taking over the world yeah
basically basically yeah and the future
is uh looking bright for alireza ruja as
well he's only 20 years old and here he
is playing a big match against Magnus
Carlsen he has been able to make a big
comeback first of all how impressed are
you with that David that he was able to
make that comeback in that must win
situation yeah so many impressive
factors first he found an opening that
Magnus was uncomfortable with unfamiliar
with which is hard enough in itself then
the middle game he managed to spin it in
his favor he won a pawn that creative
under promotion promoting to a knight in
chess happens once in a thousand games
and he found the right moment and the
finishing technique all of it put
together shows why he's so classy yeah
and right now everyone we are waiting
for the bids from Magnus and alireza the
lowest bid can decide colors probably
will choose to play with the black
pieces the player with the white pieces
has to win the game to uh win the match
what do you expect now Simon when it
comes to the bidding
um I I think Razer will want to have
white because he he's really causing
Magnus a lot of problems sort of white
pieces so I I don't think the bid will
be too low from him I reckon um let's go
13 and a half minutes yeah so that's
what I'm reckon 13 and a half so how
about Magnus do you expect he wants the
black pieces I reckon I'd be happy to
have black as well but
um let's say 13. yeah
wow that's hi Simon I was expecting
eight nine minutes that tends to be
magnus's average around eight and a half
maybe
um I think he'd be okay with black as
long as he had enough time so I'll say
nine and a nine in a bit and the bids
are in let's take a look at the bids for
the Armageddon Magnus Crossing against
Ali Reza in the big final eight minutes
56 seconds where Magnus Carlsen nine
minutes ten seconds for future that
means Magnus Carlson juices colors do
you think that is very low you anchor or
around what you expected well I kind of
expected Magnus to go around that
because I remember him and Hikaru were
doing some crazy bids but uh yeah Magnus
is confident with the black pieces so
it's gonna be interesting Bally Reza if
he plays with white pieces has to win on
demand again exactly yeah and with 15
minutes because he will have 15 minutes
with a white piece that's how difficult
will that even be for Magnus with 8
minutes 56 seconds it's gonna be a real
challenge for Magnus especially if
elevator can play like he did in that
last game both players have struck with
white that will boost for rouge's
confidence now and I think this is uh
yeah a real 50 50 could go either way
too hot to cool it's gonna be another
must win then for Ali reservous with the
white pieces and 15 minutes on the clock
Magnus Carlsen going as low as eight
minutes 56 seconds I think he's opened a
window Magnus getting ready after losing
game four and here comes the 20 year old
the new generation alireza fuja feeling
confident and winning game four is that
momentum change important for him now
yes surely and uh as long as he starts
fast I think that's the main thing uh um
again we've seen it a few times
throughout this tournament and if you
can keep your lead on the clock you will
get chances no matter what and it's a
repeat it's the exact same opening and
Magnus raises his eyebrows uh he's like
how dare you do that to me twice uh and
uh okay this time he's come ready he
plays the move A6 that's not what we saw
earlier and a double fearing keto
pushing both the G and B pawns forward
whites Bishops are gonna line up on the
longest possible diagonals interesting
play he's playing a slower approach
either you attacking the Armageddon or
you keep the tension and try to win on
the clock confuses maybe mixing matching
doing both and
no increment in this game Magnus Carlsen
with a win or Draw will be the winner of
the Julius bear generation cup if aloe
reservous wins this game he will take it
to a grand final reset with best out of
two games
it's uh now or never for Ali reservous
yeah and we want to see more chess of
course but for Asia he still needs to
win this game first and at least in
terms of opening it's much healthier for
Magnus no King problems the last thing
you want in Armageddon chassis to be
facing an attack like he was in the last
game with a king stranded in the center
both sides have developed very naturally
I think magnets would be a lot happier
in this game than the last game you had
in the same opening because well look at
his King he's managed the castle it for
a start which is which is a big
Improvement and this is more positional
by by Nature compared to that game
because uh it was all that last game was
all about keeping the tempo up from Ali
razer's perspective and stopping Black
from castling this this position is
going to revolve around the center and
you can see white putting pressure on
that and possibly a weak black pawn in
the center uh so definitely more
positional this game do you think Magnus
will be comfortable playing with that
weak born
I think so I think I think he plays
these positions quite a lot and this is
where having the draw in hand is is very
handy because isolated Pawn positions
they often give what the person playing
against them white in this case the
advantage the black pawn in the middle
if you're not sure what isolate Pawn is
is weak it can't be defended by another
uh Pawn there but they often they often
end up going to a draw with correct
defense so I think he'd be quite happy
with this Magnus to be honest uh yeah I
agree Simon I've seen too many games
where Magnus takes the isolated Queen's
Pawn as black this Pawn on D5 he trades
off the right assortment of pieces he's
left with one weakness but one weakness
is not enough for the opponent to win
the game and I've actually yeah I've
spoken to him about it a few times as
well he's very confident in these
positions he's not worried at all about
the structural defects here and this
last move also really nice uh in terms
of breaking the white coordination the
White Queen was sitting pretty defending
her Knight in the center of the board
but now she's been hit either you have
to move her to some really awkward
squares or you have to blow this attack
from the Bishop from the black Bishop
against the White Queen and that's not
pleasant either
a really tough choice of slowed down the
six minute time advantage that he had at
the start of the game has now become
under five minutes and uh I think he
really needs to up that pace again if he
wants to win this game Magnus
it's done a good job only investing one
minute to this point so far
yeah
has done a great job
and uh Ali Reza using the time on the
clock and there we see him Retreat the
night I didn't quite like this move
because it was self-pinning
it's very passive and it felt like it
was a little bit loose
and I'm just if I were Magnus I would be
just thinking about either stepping the
queen forward or this one which one I
preferred just to introduce the Rook to
the open lines
really awkward move I guess this is the
first sign we've seen from furusia that
he's desperate in this must win
situation for the full point and this uh
this kind of night Retreat that he's
gone for
its last resort type of thing it's
basically if you see no other attractive
options maybe you thought others would
lead to simplifications Trade Center
draw
so he's put his Knight on a bad Square
now he's blocked in White's light
squared Bishop he's breaking the rules
here you can't do that and also take a
look at the white king it's on an open
diagonal
I just feel like and and then the bishop
now comes to a loose Square
loose pieces drop off this feels really
vulnerable and really kind of edgy from
Frozen not in a good way
okay how does black take advantage
though thinking
push the pawn push the B Pawn forward
and that is that possible or is there
some
attacking that White Knight on the edge
yeah that makes sense
he needs to move Magnus though he's
spent 30 seconds on this move and that's
too long in Armageddon chess especially
when there's no real calculation to be
done it's just about feeling peace
placement you don't get extra time this
is such a key thing so so he has gone
for your movie van and um the the
problem is that this this time ticking
down you can get flagged a lot and Ali
raises very quick when he wants to be
but good move here I like this move you
I like the way that Magnus is playing
aggressive uh giving himself this
isolate Pawn but he's keeping up the
activity and white has the decision now
to make where that Knight goes into it
has two tempting squares there David I
guess going into B6 or C5 both of those
Dart squares yeah the Knight could also
retreat but no real tempting options
there Virgil wants to jump forward with
this Knight but there might be tactics
and white pieces are so loose right now
especially the white Dart squared Bishop
sitting uh kind of stared down by the
black Rook indirectly right now watch
out for the black Bishop to jump out the
way at the right moment and uh unleash
and discovered attack it's actually
really tricky because if you where'd You
Go I mean like if you go to B2 there's
also Bishop A3 so maybe this is one of
the only squares which is reasonably
safe here but uh the white pieces are
lacking Harmony here uh if you could put
the pawn on F3 back on F2 where the
light Square Bishop is going then great
but Magnus just improving uh each move
looking good for Magnus so far but not
on the clock
yeah and uh Ali Reza will have to go on
full-on calculation mode as he had to
anticipate black porn stepping forward
and Magnus responding quickly with a
bishop coming to a through A3 the bishop
is threatening to come to B2
and once again
alireza is being asked questions
big big trouble for Alaris on the board
simply he's got no coordination look at
White's pieces we talked about traffic
jam earlier in the day the white pieces
are around the white king they keep the
king safe but they're not active they're
just passive they're stuck and there's
holes meanwhile on the other flank
that's why Magnus is invaded now uh this
black dark Square Bishop is uh ivanka's
pointing out here is creating some
threats Black's pawns as well in the
center holding the space holding the
territory here white has no attractive
moves no active moves you can't grab
this isolated Queen's Pawn black pawn in
the center of the board with the white
knight because uh the other white knight
would be hanging there and look at this
Magnus is just saying I'm going to keep
coming forward keep pouring forward
evaluation Bar says maybe there were
better moves but this looks really
beautiful you've locked down this flank
now the queen side is blacks and alarisa
needs to fight back
yeah and magnus's pieces are threatening
to Spring Forward because the light
Square Bishop is also threatening to
mobilize to F5 and hit at the C2 point
and white species are just in a cluster
they're not doing anything there on the
right side of the board
have a six minute time Advantage he
started the game with farrugia it's now
three minutes it's been halved and uh
already momentum on black side I think
that's only going to uh increase that
pattern I think he's got to keep playing
quickly Ali razor here if you can keep
playing at a decent pace when I say
quickly obviously take a bit of time to
think
um then he keeps chances alive because
uh the position all the pieces are on
the board it's not that bad for white at
all blacks pieces are a bit better but
it's still okay and you're gonna get the
some chances at some point maybe just
move the queen up one square play a
logical move like that connect the Rooks
connecting the Rooks is a very good idea
because you want to use your Rooks to
get into the game into the middle
um something along those lines and but I
think he's got he's got to keep the pace
up uh he doesn't want to get down to an
equal situation on time and have a
slightly worse position yeah and Magnus
made a bit of a face there he was like
oh you're still thinking come on speed
up and uh Queen D2 Simon I like it move
the white Queen
could play the move G4 start pushing
pawns do something towards the black
king take away squares you have to just
decide yeah For Better or Worse no
tempting options here you just have to
kind of trust your instincts and I like
your G4 because it is a must-wing game
why not you take away the F5 Square for
uh the bishop and you push push the
pawns on the king side basically I like
that idea uh you know this is this is
kind of alirez's style as well uh attack
so um what's he gonna play I spent a lot
of time here yeah
and that must be so uncomfortable no you
have to play fast you know you have to
speed up it's frozen yeah yeah well he's
made his move oh is that a blunder and
you can just see the evaluation bar just
zoom all the way down in Black's favor
I think Bishop F5 is just a move with
very logical move here yeah let's show
this this is a big mistake while the
computer says there's something even
stronger uh Bishop's F5 looks very good
hitting this Pawn but the whole idea is
that the White Knight would
counter-attack against this bishop and
keep the game going black still better
but minimizing the damage the winning
move here on the spot plus five
Advantage for Magnus if he finds it is
Pawn to D4 taking away that Square from
the White Knight you cannot take it with
oh he doesn't find it can't take it with
the Knight now because the night the
other night would be hanging on C3 uh
this would lose a piece after The Rook
takes here but uh if you take with
another piece for example the bishop
only now Bishop F5 would have won the
game on the spot crashing in on C2 uh
Magnus doesn't see it but still in the
driver's seat Port H5 can't be a bad
move maybe trying to loosen up the white
king side over here stopping G4 as well
and just gaining a bit more space I did
spend a lot of time before he made that
Rook move could there be some sort of a
trap he wants to set here
I think he just missed that D4 uh Pawn
push I think he was hoping for the black
Bishop to land on F5 so he could spring
forward Knight D4 and at least it's
slightly messy
but it's okay again now right I mean uh
I mean I say okay it's it's still a game
on you know he's not losing immediately
uh he's just worse here but magnus's
time again you know look at it ticked
down you don't get any extra time if
Magnus gets to one minute no matter what
the position is he can get flagged
um he can lose on time so uh and he's
getting near that that stage already now
and we did see uh those uh images from
the bullet Chess Championship between
these two they are quite good at bullet
chess both of them as well but who would
be the favorite if we're down to the
minute I mean they were taking yeah I
mean they were punching each other they
were hitting each other striking
knocking lumps out of each other uh
trading blows there it was so close I
think they've won one match each against
each other in that I think Ali razor won
the first one and then they're so close
aren't they they're just both brilliant
bullet players but uh Magnus simplifying
things here by making an exchange
simplifying it looks good at least from
a practical point of view he's getting
pieces off the board he's temporary
rarely sacrificed tonight as black to
lure the White Queen onto the sea file
where she stared down by a black rook
and now
forgetting the material next turn this
white knight will disappear on C3
pausing I'm not sure why he's got to
take that Knight in Armageddon chess you
can't burn 10 seconds on a forced move
what else is he thinking about he's got
to take the piece yeah there we go he
does eventually go for it but okay still
a two in a bit minute Advantage for
farrugia at least now the pawn structure
is in balance
okay he's really fighting back uh
alireza here I would not write him off
at all I mean again uh black is better
here because Black's pieces have more
space more more area to breathe
um all the blacks pieces better than
White's pieces but white is quite solid
and white has a sizable time advantage
and these things do count uh you know
there's no obvious way that Magnus can
break through in this uh in this
position but having said that there is a
big dilemma for alireza on the board you
know he has to recapture that Rook does
he recapture it with a rook and allow
black to retreat the bishop and pin the
Knight or is he Rich capturing with a
bishop which does expose the king are
both of them tempting well they're not
tempting that's the whole point they're
they're both unattractive in their own
way so okay see he does capture with a
rook and there we see Magnus step back
with a bishop and now the Knight on C3
is pinned
but you know what at White's position he
he's he's uh if he can get out of this
pin his pieces his Bishop in the middle
of the board they're starting to look
quite nicer white I mean uh it's it's
improving for Aly razor definitely he's
also always got a threat of taking the
Black Knight opening up magnus's King
massive improvement from alireza just
over the last few moves Magnus maybe not
finding the killer blow it's hard to in
Armageddon when you're watching the
clock and okay he's curled up into a
ball he's defended everything Magnus has
traded off his beautiful Bishop uh in
order to win a Pawn on A2 okay
materialistic maybe this is uh the way
to go but still Anything Can Happen the
bishop pair for white have great
potential
you need something now though alireza
and I mean you've got just imagine white
at some point going Bishop takes knight
uh black would have to recapture and the
black king is opened up but fortunately
the white king is very weak as well on
the first two ranks there's a lot of air
you can see going towards White's King
so black has counter attacks with his
Rook coming down the board to check the
king and this this would be a very
tragic a bishop coming in adding to the
Firepower there so that that move you
can't play now but it's always there as
a threat Magnus taking another Pawn
um wow this is this is really now
getting to the critical critical point
oh
alireza pushes his pawns forward this is
just him taking risks in a must win
situation uh that's not the move he
wanted to play if he was happy with the
draw there maybe he could have slapped
off the Black Knight Queens would have
come off in a draw but okay he's got to
win here and Magnus is off the board
great move there brilliant move love it
look at how he's going to trade queens
now there we go Queens have been they
said it costs black oppon but he had two
extra pawns anyway Magnus is playing for
the draw here that's all he needs to
look at the clock he's only 30 seconds
down he's a massive favorite to hold
this but two Bishops a white uh there's
some space Advantage it's still game on
uh definitely Magnus is over the worst
now and there's some little tricks here
if you try to move your king upwards to
get out of the out of the pin uh there's
a pawn check but you know there's still
chances here definitely still chances
white does have the ability to push
forward with the pawns and at the right
time if he can then if he manages to
release the light Square Bishop then
it's still very much gonna be anyone's
game because blast King is in potential
trouble so that's how Ali Reza is
thinking can he just step forward with
the G Pawn look at his time tonight he's
now caught and overtaken Magnus on the
clock as well that was the thing I was
saying you need to really keep that time
Advantage no matter what because it
gives you another way to win the game if
things start to go wrong you can just
play moves you don't even have to play
the best moves just play moves and win
on the clock but he's really he's really
sinking into a think here yeah maybe
yeah maybe alireza has to activate his
Rook put it
seven
to do something he has to do something
nice to do it quickly here simply if he
had more time in the clock if he still
had a two minute time Advantage he could
even trade Rooks and play on that
position forever and ever and ever
opposite color Bishops whatever just to
try and win on the clock but
that option is gone he will never win on
time now alireza he needs to win on the
board he's a pawn down he's pulling down
he's got it okay this this the move that
Ivanka recommended looks like a good try
you've got to try to get your pieces
into the game Magnus moves quickly
Magnus threatening to win a piece now
with that Bishop he just moved coming
down to add pressure to White's light
Square Bishop he can come all the way
down that light Square Bishop is pinned
so Ali razor is threatened with quite a
nasty move there and he's got to find a
way to deal with it and look at the time
as well he's down three minutes now yeah
David is that it's really difficult to
deal with that threat of the bishop
coming into F1 if you step back with the
King you're just going to get checked
and that's why Ali Reza's had to sound
the retreat but unfortunately now it's
the night that's going to spring forward
to the F4 Square Black's piece is taking
over here I mean I know White's got the
two Bishops but the two Bishops are
really bad especially the bishop by
White's King it can't move it's in a pin
and that black knight as you said you
think is just threatening to come and
attack it again you've also got an extra
Pawn it's quite handy isn't it as well
so
alirez's body language is not positive
right now he knows that he's on the
brink of elimination and he's come close
he's taking it to Armageddon but how is
he ever going to win this position of
Pawn down facing this pin on the second
rank the deadly pin there his Bishop's
now getting kicked around the board and
uh black has various ways to guide this
game to safety let alone uh yeah let
them maybe even claim for the win if
Magnus is feeling ambitious uh first I'm
expecting him to maybe even lock down
the kingside second rank pin is not
going to go away anytime soon Black's a
pawn could start running as well the
past one that's the side you have the
extra Pawn after all
there's still some tiny hope for white
because white if they manage to push the
F Pawn forward can uh one day release
that light Square Bishop so I like your
idea of locking everything down yeah
it's a great move I mean there's always
hope in Armageddon as well isn't there
you always have a chance with the nerves
on show suddenly Magnus uh having this
long thing we've seen it a few times
long think wrong thing when uh farusha
was tanking earlier he made a mistake
after investing a lot of time will
Magnus do the same wow he's jumped in
with his Knight oh he's trying to go for
the draw he's not playing for the win
here Magnus Carlson he's just giving up
his night after the white Rook takes
it's been lured away and Simon's idea
black Bishop jumping to F1 winning that
pinned there we go winning that pinned
white bishop and notice how the
remaining Bishops on the board will be
of opposite color so this one almost
dead drone now yeah I mean uh unless
your Bishop gets in some trouble but I
don't think it does I mean yeah this
this uh
obviously should be a draw now uh
White's pieces slightly better though so
white can try to get in but opposite
color Bishops I mean uh these are
these are notoriously drawn positions I
mean the Bishops the reason they're so
drawn is the Bishops can never connect
uh they can never challenge each other
so they can keep passing each other in
the wind there because they're on
different colored squares so they always
just drift by meaning that they can't
hit the same Target so a draw becomes
very likely and uh whilst a draw might
be likely it's not the result that
alireza wants and uh bearing in mind
that if there's any side that is pushing
for the win it's going to be black with
that extra pawn and the bishop attacking
the H3 Pawn there and Magnus just uh ask
a question to the C5 Bishop there is a
check the king can hide but when he's
going in there's only one weak spot in
Black's camp and that is the Pawn on the
dance Square on G7 next to black king
he's gonna try and hit it with his Rook
next move but I can be easily guarded
against
and uh Magnus can start trading off
pawns if he needs to a lot of time on
the clock even without Black's a pawn I
think this is an easy draw for someone
of magnus's caliber you you almost feel
like the white king is on danger of
getting eject mated if you can remove
some of his Escape squares
been spending a lot of time though
Magnus it means you're getting under two
minutes now this is where it just gets
really random you lose on time no
increment you lose the game and that's
quite an aggressive move he's checking
the king and he's he's securing the draw
right and now the Rook is going to come
down Checkmate Checkmate hurry yeah with
Harry and with the Rook H4 that'd be a
very appropriate way to finish the match
I feel checkmate with Harry and uh there
it goes into the board and he's now
taking some pawns and is there any way
the black king can get in danger here
um I mean I don't see it but the black
king is a little bit short of squares
but
you need to get you you need to get the
white king the only chance now I think
is for the white king to try to encroach
on the black King's position and to get
a checkmating net around it or to win on
time
um or for magnus's internet to go down
or foreign
times were reversed he might be starting
to feel a bit panicky but okay he has
paused here he just needs to get all
whites remaining pawns off the board and
make sure he doesn't get checkmated
those two things either or will
guarantee the draw now and look as he
secure this but look at the clock
they're going to get under a minute and
they're playing very slowly I mean you
can just flag These are times where you
you know you're going to get real tense
finish to this because in a moment look
at him
I think he's like what what am I doing
I'm spending far too long but now it's a
private game white has the chance to
actually push the F Pawn to F5 and
create like some kind of attack on the
black king you know Magnus here he's
banking on the black Rook sliding behind
the white king with the check and uh
there's some Targets on the e-file pin
oh always drop what's happened here
though okay but the H4 now surely can
forwards yeah and that H Pawn is two is
a couple of squares of queening but they
are playing so calm for under a minute
now uh they and but this could be a
killer there's a big fret H2 H1 Queen
and I don't think there's any check
maintenance there the only chance is to
go F5 as you said uvanka Bishop takes
Pawn maybe you could try that here push
the pawn to F5 H2 Bishop takes F6
threatening Checkmate could be could be
worth it is the only chance that white
has otherwise the age Pawn is just gonna
Queen and he's setting it up and Magnus
has to be careful and Magnus is
oh the black king has some light squares
to escape to Magnus finally kind of
makes a head movement and he knows he's
winning his Pawn is soon going to
promote first he gives a check
okay still a bit nervous here but 22
seconds for farrugia it surely isn't
enough to even complete this game
I mean yeah but that was a nervy check
there they are they are so nervous in
this match you can see it and a lot of
fun coming forward giving up his Rook
wow he's giving up his Rook to try and
promote the black F Pawn but uh White's
Rook would then have to give itself up
and that would have been a draw Magnus
is going to win on the clock here 12
seconds 10 seconds now for alireza this
one is over look the Pawn's about to
promote yeah he's going for checkmate
but this is forlorn yeah black queen on
the board now is going to win this game
Magnus he's got it he's got it in the
end wow what a fight though that was
amazing over Magnus Carl sen he takes it
this is the winner of the Julia's very
generation cup after an exciting final
match here against alireza verucia who
took it to Armageddon but eventually
Magnus calls and he wins his third event
in the Champions chess tour at 2023 with
a very exciting performance here and a
good performance by Magnus yvanka
impressed by the world number one yeah I
mean he pulled it together you know
because it must have been a really
frustrating fourth game loss for Magnus
but uh come for the Armageddon and he
has his opening Improvement ready and he
just played as if he meant business yeah
very impressive game it's been a battle
of generations uh Simon does Magnus
prove that well his generation with him
in the lead is still the best in the
world the old guys are still doing well
at the moment so yeah but who knows how
much longer that will last I mean Ali
razor was playing really good at moments
during
and we're joined by uh Magnus Carlsen
the winner of the Julius bear generation
cup congrats Magnus
intense uh finally especially with that
final uh rapid game and heading to
Armageddon how do you feel about how
this day went for you
uh
um
[Music]
I just
it was not my day at all today
um
I think to be honest I think I was
pretty lucky
um
to to even make it to the Armageddon
unfortunately I got a position that was
pretty easy to play in the Armageddon
but my brain was not working today
um
that's all
um I I had a um
um I had a nice dinner with my family
before before I played and uh even
before that I could feel that I it was
not working
um but I guess especially after that I
was just I was just that so I'm super
relieved to to have won the match
um and I think that's some days like
some days are good some days
um you've got to try and get through and
that was one of this was one of them and
I'm really happy that I did so do you
think that is down to your experience
then that on a bad day where you feel
drained you are actually able to Win It
[Music]
mostly most of that even on bad days I
can usually sort of
sort of compute
yeah it was um was tough Maybe
maybe he could have
pounced a bit earlier in the first rapid
games could have been out for Bloods
like a little more especially in the
first game like I have I mean I had a
terrible position and I had no time uh
so I think he had a great chance there
but um
yeah it was um yeah was this a day also
then when aloe Reza didn't take the
chances that you have to take if you're
gonna beat uh yourself in a match
yeah I think that's uh that's exactly
um exactly right that um
he needed to be um even crisper than he
was obviously he's really really strong
and on the day like this he posts me a
lot of problems but
um
in the in the critical moments were both
kind of uh floundering a bit and um yeah
for him that was just about not enough
um Magnus congratulations sir did you
feel the elevator did anything different
from the last match could you tell that
he maybe adopted a different strategy
this time
to be honest I just think that I played
worse I think that was the main
difference yeah so um
um
frankly I didn't feel like anybody
except
I had a really good tournament from
from the others so
um yeah
um all the rest of it was I think pretty
good in his match against Wesley
otherwise
I was um I I think he's played better in
the past
yeah this uh congratulations Magnus I
just wanted to ask you did uh starting
two hours later impact your routine
um well it meant that I had time to join
my family for dinner which was nice
apart from that
um
not really like I just woke up today
um well fairly late but feeling really
well rested but also
um also without much energy and
yeah maybe I needed to change things up
a bit today to to get that energy
I was just hoping I would be able to get
through get through it and the fact that
you are feeling a little drained Magnus
is it coming off a long World Cup
playing here in the generation cup uh do
you need a break now is that what you
feel
maybe a little bit
um I am taking a
day break from tomorrow so
I'll be um I'll be away for um for about
a week
and will that break include uh training
playing chess or is it to get chests off
your head
well it wouldn't be a proper vacation
without looking at NHS because I love
Jess it's like it's been my biggest
hobby as well as work for uh
for such a long time so I'm not going to
be completely away from it for instance
a speed Chess Championship is starting
so I'm going to be following that for
sure
um but I probably won't be playing much
all right and I also have to ask you
minus this is a skinnier in a role that
you win the Julius bird generation cup
proving that you are still the best in
the world when do you expect the Next
Generation with players like furuja
gukesh to take over
um it's kind of up to them to them
really like they have they have what it
takes but um
the final boss of Chess is um usually
pretty tough
all right I'm Magnus after like winning
everything uh that can be won pretty
much um how do you like stay motivated
is it just your love of Chess or uh is
there anything else you want to win
you can always win things again no but I
I think what I play for is days like my
first game against alresa you know
Sicilians feeling good
feeling the flow and so on
um
I just yeah I love playing uh and I love
the feeling of winning still so
that's enough for me
and Magnus it's been a big week for you
uh of course the Highlight though is
surely the release of a book I think uh
one of the co-authors in the studio any
words about that one
um yeah uh can I get a copy
I'll send you one growing like a grand
master out now no no I'm I'm looking
looking forward to looking forward to it
and um did you pick the title for that
book yes
uh I think David is the one who came up
with um with the title and uh Concepts
um
to be honest like he did most of the
work for um for the course and all the
work for the book so
um he's the one who should be um
is the one who should be praised and uh
he is the
the real Grand Master
some beautiful words start for David
Magnus big congratulations on another
win and enjoy your vacation
thank you so much and uh good to have
you back as well Kyle thank you thank
you Magnus
all right he is the winner Magnus Carl's
not the Julius bear generation cup and
that was that was an uh incredible
performance by him losing only two games
in this tournament today's match alireza
Borussia losing game three was able to
make a great comeback in game four to
take it too Armageddon but we do see
Magnus uh getting two brilliances and
today and the accuracy 84 percent
what do you think about that I think
that just reflected the complexity of
the games the nerves we're used to maybe
higher numbers from both players but uh
they entertained us and that's the main
thing
Simon how are you Samuel the Julius bear
generation cup what has impressed you
what do you feel about the battle
between the generations it's been great
all the way through I I did like those
Sicilian games I I love that action but
um other things that have been very
impressive Dennis the young Dennis 16
years old played such great chess I
think he's going to be a real uh name
and player to to keep an eye on for for
the future so he he was a highlight as
well this tournament yeah the Magnus
Carlsen is the winner with some
incredible play and I hear rumors we
have some very nice stats here minus
crossing the jewels very generation Cup
winner overall event performance
look at that wins with the black pieces
four
winning with uh Armageddon here accuracy
almost 90 throughout the tournament
total news played 950. what's your
reaction to this David firstly that's a
lot of moves yeah we wish you got paid
by the move here but uh either way
impressive stuff in terms of accuracy
considering how many complicated games
he had interesting that he's gone back
to basics uh we talked about generation
cup he's gone he's gone back to what he
knows best playing E4 playing the
Sicilian as black his uh favorite
openings there but uh yeah impressive
stats either way yeah I was really
impressed by the fact there's only been
one Armageddon so I mean
I mean I expected more but anyhow
magna's been very very impressive and
I'm very impressed by his performance
today because he said it you know he
felt tired he felt out of sorts but
still he managed to beat Ali Reza in one
game in a very impressive game I have to
say and also in the Armageddon it made
it look very clean I think there was
that list of the top three players in
the world which I think it was ajramata
a very famous YouTuber said and it was a
Magnus Carlsen number one and then it
was uh maybe Magnus when partying number
two then number three it was a a tired
Magnus I think and so the list goes on
even a tired Magnus Carlson is a very
dangerous Magnus Carlson if it feels
often talk about his motivation do you
think Magnus Carlson seems very
motivated right now David I mean he
seems happy he was talking of his love
of Chess I mean if I was on holiday I'm
not sure I would be uh checking out the
latest games the latest opening
developments but he seems to be in a
happy place right now in the zone uh
still grinding out those results even if
he doesn't feel at his best
um long may that continue I think the
new generation as well they want him to
be at his best when they uh finally
catch him so yeah it's a good time for
the Chess World yeah definitely and only
one regular event remain in the
Champions chess tour 2023 Magnus Carlsen
is guaranteed a spot in the next event
and also in the tour finals in Toronto
five out of eight spots have been taken
most recently with Wesley so and Fabiano
Corona qualifying but three spots are
still up for grabs and Ali Reza of
Russia while he is qualified for that
final sixth event and he is Five Points
behind Denis lazovic it's gonna be a
battle for those points in event six to
make it to Toronto who do you hope and
who do you think we're gonna see there
in Toronto
um I kind of hope that Ali Reza faruja
and Dennis lazovic because he's such an
exciting Talent only 16 years old will
make it to Toronto
um it's going to be exciting because
what I love about this event is that you
have the big plans where every Grand
Master is allowed to play in that and it
could be anyone actually if they have a
great week great day being there in
Toronto yeah and I I think you've got to
remember that netpost playing the next
plane as well right and uh well he's
such a great player that's going to be
it's going to be very exciting so yeah
yeah division one is going to be stacked
it's going to be a huge event uh
remember whoever wins that can still
book their place in Toronto at least two
rating spots therefore or two ranking
spots uh on points Stakes are higher
than ever and we're closing another
season finale it's been a great year
it's going to get even better yeah it is
lead to
players we are nearing the end of the
2023 season and the fight to secure a
spot at the finals is definitely on
Magnus Carlson Hikaru Nakamura and
nordibec Abdu satrov have already
qualified through winning individual
events plus Wesley so and Fabiana
caruana punched their tickets with tour
points and now only three spots Remain
the finale will be played from December
9th to 16th in Toronto Canada follow to
see who will get a chance to fight for
the 2023 Champions chess tour title
it's going to be one of the most
exciting events on the chess calendar in
Toronto in December and actually you can
get tickets to the tour finals by
bidding on the Julius bear generation
Cup trophy owning the trophy comes with
tickets for the tour final and you can
submit your bids at chess champs.io
and we also have to announce another
winner we had the quiz today and uh the
question today the final question in the
Julia spread generation cup was in 2006
visionon crossed 2 800 in rating as the
fourth player in history who were the
three other players who had achieved
this at the time
let's take a look at the answer
okay Kasparov and topalov correct I'm
very confident about those two then I've
put chronic because I know he did but I
think it might have been a bit later
I'll say kramnik is my third okay and
you Simon okay
um yeah I've gone kaspara from tapalov
as well and I did also go for Fisher
which is a bit back in the uh it seemed
logical so he was a good player so one
of you have all three correct I must be
cram Nick it's gonna be absolutely
it was a dream it was a dream away in
those days I think you've got 27.90 yeah
yeah he was but David you've got all
three correct you get one point and you
are the winner of the quiz
congratulations
good work day thank you he knows his
chess history this man let's go back
it's been a good day for you David
winning the go-kart winning the quiz
what can I say I'm lucky I'm sorry Simon
you'll get me next time I'm not sure if
you technically won the go-karting
because on the leaderboard I did the
faster lap I said number one and we have
evidence of that but just just to put
that straight
you did you won I'll give you that one
sorry one well done so I guess that
David as well will win one of these
great t-shirts and let's take a look who
won the T-shirt
from you guys at home answering because
viral kramnik and top love SLK chess is
the winner and will receive Simon's you
resign now t-shirt this is super cool
it has not been worn why Simon Williams
I'm sorry I bet you would prefer a worn
t-shirt but um
you guys it's been so much fun being
back in the studio with you guys
learning about Chess enjoying some drama
hope you enjoyed it Kyle so good to have
you back with us it's been very fun and
still one event's regular event left in
the Champions chess store 2023 it's
starting in only three weeks so we will
be back very soon it's been so much fun
having you guys with us for the Julius
bear generation cup and we'll see you
soon again
[Music]
okay what swapping Queens when you were
pulling down
Sunday's game on yeah yeah and Magnus
leans forward is like he heard you there
David that is a heartbreak for verusa
Magnus Carlsen wins
Splendid I we heading to Armageddon I
think we are
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]